[Music]
homie look what I become
you would know cause you live there
right wow it just I got blanks in
different areas that's what it is okay
all right area code today's episode is
303 apparently that's a Colorado area
code we got a special guest here for it
Larry Elder the great Larry Elder here
who uh uh you know he's got a lot to say
he's uh running for office the black
face of white supremacist yeah yeah I
can't believe you I can't believe it
Larry went there right now I work hard
work hard for the title come on
there we go tell them the black face the
white supremacy he is a political
commentator uh conservative radio uh
host uh the Larry Elder show based in
California the show began local in uh
KABC in 1993 ran until 2008 and then his
second show KBC from 2010 to 2014
announced with Salem Radio Tom are you
okay are you spazzing out what is Tom
doing I don't know Pat no just a it's
okay what happened no I just had to give
a signal to Rob what's the signal tell
us what the signal is now we have to
pause to find what the Signal's about go
ahead uh I think Larry's mic is way too
low we can hardly that was just me I was
being oh okay exactly Tom you're gonna
be okay I wish we could focus on Tom Tom
was spent I thought for a second I was
having a seizure yeah but Tom's okay
okay so he authored a book to go to bed
it's what they told me to say ask as
goes California my mission to rescue the
Golden State and save the nation by the
way he still hasn't left he's one of the
only ones that stayed behind I think
he's going to be the last one to leave
foreign that book comes out by the way
in November I also have a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame but I was about
to say that which is pretty ridiculous
amazing he's got a Hollywood star
right next to uh Mary Pickford April 27
2015. you know who Mary Pickford is it
on Vine is he the little guy on on uh
yeah did you do everything this was
going to happen no okay so what no no no
um I didn't even care about movies when
I was a little kid my brother my older
brother Kirk loved love love movies we
go down to Hollywood and go down to the
Hollywood Walk of Fame he knew all the
stars and I'm like bored and fast
forward I get one it's it's just
it's just beyond uh beyond my
comprehension it really is I think it's
pretty sick for that to happen I I think
it's right there if you can focus in and
yeah they have a few uh radio guys who
have them but it's a handful of friends
Scully Casey Kasem yeah and Larry Elder
yeah that's amazing Arthur Godfrey
doesn't does Howard Stern have one or
now you no he does not not that I know
of I don't know yeah he wouldn't leave
his house
get the star on the Hollywood Walk of
Fame pardon me what year did uh 2015. do
you think you would get it today in
today's political climate no I I was
surprised I got it then I've been
nominated many times I never got it and
I get a phone call and they're telling
me that that I got it so that's great
well congratulations that's a big deal
and you're running right now for
President right ran for governor of
California I got three and a half
million votes which is kind of
interesting because I didn't make the
first debate stage and the whole point
behind having criteria is to make sure
that anybody that fogs up a mirror who
thinks he wants to run president can't
demand a spot on the debate stage and I
get that but I ran for governor got
three and a half million votes
there were 46 people who wanted to
replace Gavin do some I finished number
one of the of all the other replacement
candidates I got 49 of the total vote on
the replacement side the next highest
person and they were independent
Republicans and Democrats that ran next
highest person got nine percent highest
Republican after me got seven percent
and then I got in with just eight weeks
left in eight weeks I raised 27 million
dollars 150 000 individual donors half
of them came from outside of California
uh California has 58 counties on the
replacement side I carried 57 and 58 and
by the way I wasn't the state party
person that they wanted they wanted a
guy named Kevin Faulkner who's a
two-term mayor of San Diego the National
Party wanted Faulkner
Uh Kevin McCarthy told all the
Republicans in the house in California
to stay out of the race unless it was
Kevin Faulkner I carried San Diego
County by 30 points and I thought at
some point when it was obvious I was the
guy the base wanted that the national
and state party would either endorse me
or give me some verbal support or give
me some money they didn't either
so so why do you think they didn't is it
because I was I wasn't the guy uh I
wasn't establishment I was I was
complete complete total Grassroots I
mean I never ran for anything I didn't
think I was going to get into the race
the others had been running for months I
got in the last minute and I I went to
the top right away I mean you said it so
fast as if it's a you know not a big
deal 27 million dollars eight weeks 150
000 donors 50 right not in the state of
California and and by the way there was
a recall election in 2003 in California
that's how Gavin uh that's how uh Arnold
Schwarzenegger became Governor since
then there are five percent more
registered Democrats in California there
are 33 registered fewer registered
Republicans and 50 more registered
Independents in Independence and
California vote Democrat so with the
battlefield far more daunting I did just
as well as Arnold Schwarzenegger he got
49 I got 49 why do you think it wasn't
even close and uh Newsome won it and it
wasn't even like a congress it was 61 63
ended up being sixty percent what do you
think I got outspent about ten to one
and for a while the recall part was in
the margin of error and they were scared
bleepless in came Obama in came Joe
Biden in came all the money teachers
union and they turned it around and he
ended up keeping his job pretty
comfortably however he had to spend 50
more to return to retain his job that he
did to get his job
um but they turned into a national race
they said uh if you watch the
commercials
and I can count the ridges on my
thumbnail because of it I I've taken one
picture with Donald Trump both of those
are thumbs up so every commercial
was a picture of Elder and Trump side by
side with our thumbs up and the line was
always the same stop the Republican
takeover
nobody said Gavin Newsom was doing a
great job the way he shut down the state
in a more severe way than anybody else
Gavin do some doing a great job on
education doing a great job on budget on
crime on homelessness they never said
that they just said stop the Republican
takeover and Republicans are outnumbered
in California three to one and that's
all they had to do
there hasn't been a republican who's won
Statewide in California in 20 years Tom
I think there's something else too it's
very very interesting is as you were
rattling off those it's because you know
them by heart but I think they're really
for people listening there needs to be
kind of a more of an understanding here
there were four uh individuals that were
in the top four including two Democrats
to be the replacement candidate
um uh which you're talking about the
number two guy Uh Kevin pavreth was a
Democrat he was a guy with nine percent
so there was people in California that
wanted this Dem to replace Gavin Newsom
and when you're talking about 3.5
million votes hats off to you for that
but when it came for the recall you got
4.9 million votes it was 38 percent in
favor of the recall and you were and you
were the recall candidate so and the
other thing I looked at I want to know
what you thought about it you just
talked about that they put you with
Trump and it was defeat trumpism and all
that but they also kind of turned it
into a mono topic election it was all
about covet this is a matter of life and
death was actually a coveted ad that
they spent more air time on than any of
the other ads even on the you and Trump
so they created this scare element is
that how you read part of it they said
that I was anti-vaccine uh even though
I've been double vaxxed you said that
you said you had been back yeah but by
opposed mandates I oppose the uh the
mass mandates I oppose the vaccine
mandates I oppose the shutdown so that
translated into Elder is anti-vax CNN
interviewed me for about a half hour
and uh I told them that young people are
not likely to get covet they're not
likely to get really sick they're not
likely to be hospitalized not likely to
die but that's not true according to the
CDC blah blah blah turns out of course I
was right yeah uh nobody said I said
they were nobody apologized the other
thing though that happened in this one
as opposed to 2003
in 2003 the Democrat lieutenant governor
ran on the replacement side as well and
that took a lot of the vote away from
Gray Davis the then incumbent so they
didn't want did not want to repeat that
same mistake there was some rumor that
the two-term former mayor of La Antonio
villaragoza a Democrat was going to run
on their placement side and I heard that
they made some sort of deal so he
wouldn't do it had he been in that race
uh it would have been a different
different ball game they paid his prior
campaign debts was one of the rumors
that's what I heard but by the way I
wasn't going to repeat that thank you
for doing that do you regret getting
back
researchers don't sue me are you at this
point do you regret getting backs or no
you're fine with the decision if I had
to do it all over again I wouldn't have
done it you wouldn't my doctor told me I
I am over 65 years old I'm 71 I know
look good black don't crack
uh I'm over 65 I have high blood
pressure and I have a rare blood uh
condition and so because of these
comorbidities are as they're called he
strongly recommends that I get
vaccinated looking back at it I I think
that and I did get covet after getting
vaccinated I think I would have been
just fine so so okay uh California why
haven't you left yet why are you still
in California this is where I'm from my
friends are there my my church is there
my memories are there
um and frankly if you are live in
California you bought a home say in the
80s you're doing very very well your
house is appreciated like crazy uh I got
a lot of equity in my in my home so I'm
living living quite well as long as I
avoid the homeless people and the uh in
the needles and yeah I'm serious about
that live in a very nice place in the
Hollywood Hills I could go maybe two or
three blocks on either side of the
street or a bunch of Vans full of people
Hollywood Hills yeah Hollywood Hills
shouldn't be living there
um there's a really real bad homeless
problem in the area where I live
um Antonio viviragosa by the way after
the recall was over said
I've never seen La look so dirty I've
never seen so much homelessness he
didn't say anything during the recall
but he said it afterwards uh it's pretty
pathetic and the Bay Area is even worse
what happened to it I mean for a guy
that's been there your entire life I
lived there 24 years when he lived there
I don't know how many years 15 years Tom
you lived there how many years 40 40
years so we're all California natives
he's a Florida guy he's actually an
Addison guy Addison Texas guy born and
raised in Madison Texas Miami but but
by way of Addison yeah yeah he's so true
that's true the evolution of this great
state that every the California Dreaming
right everybody Mamas and Papas
everybody wanted to go to this place
what happened to it
single party government Democrats uh
Democrats control the assembly the
Senate they have two-thirds majority uh
Republicans need not even show up for
work they pay us one job killing bill
after another one Freedom sapping bill
after another they're in bed with the
teachers union they're in bed with the
environmentalists uh and they've just
passed one law after another that's
undermined the middle class very wealthy
people can survive very poor people can
survive it's a middle-class people who
are leaving and uh and Larry the average
price of a home in California is 175
percent above the national average think
about that the number one reason that
people cite for leaving is they cannot
afford to buy a house and they have no
idea why they just know they can't
afford to buy one that's why when people
leave California go to places like
Colorado and Arizona they start
changing those States because they still
vote Democrat because they haven't
connected the dots huh they still vote
Democrat when they leave the state they
haven't connected the doc they don't
they don't know why all they know is
that things are not
I can't I can't get the kind of
lifestyle that I want I can get a better
lifestyle in this state that state that
state but they have no idea why so
they're just attributing it to the cost
of living yeah or or whatever and how
much is the average house in California
compared to the national uh I think the
average price of a home in California
about 800 000 yep 740 look at that I
didn't even see that I did it already
yeah nice are you impressed are you
impressed to back up what Larry's
talking about go take a look at the
history of Colorado Phoenix and Austin
excuse me Denver Phoenix and Austin it's
exactly what he's talking about where
they move in and they turn red to
Lavender and then
blue I figured it'd be the exact
opposite people leaving California being
like I can't take the restrictions I
can't take the taxes I can't take the
regulation the homelessness everything
just combined it's like I'm out of here
I'm gonna go live my life I'm an
independent thinker and move to a state
where I can just do me but you're
basically saying no they're just going
to continue their left-leaning policies
yeah even in and spend some time in
Boston they have indoctrinated people in
California to believe Republicans are
just bad people uh and anything
Republican is bad I mean we're I'm
pro-life therefore I'm anti-woman that's
not that's something that's how they
phrase it
um I believe taxes are too high
therefore I'm for the rich I mean that's
what they do and they have they have
indoctrinated a whole generation of of
people young people in California to
feel that way let me ask this question
Tom this goes to you and uh to Larry so
do you think uh you know we had teachers
protesting against DeSantis here and
they're saying you know Florida
anti-walker agenda is causing us to want
to leave the state of Florida and you
know some people in Florida are like
great go to California Right Where You
Belong yeah so so do you do you think
more uh uh Democrats are leaving red
States because they can no longer be
there and they're finding blue States or
do you think more conservatives
Republicans are leaving blue States
finding red states to go to
I think a little bit of both but I think
that
surely the the red states are the ones
that are growing uh you look at there's
a map that shows you where taxes or
taxes are going uh and they're going to
Red States uh I think people feel the
schools are better uh there's there's
less regulation a lower cost of living
greater Economic Opportunity so I think
both both Republicans and Democrats are
leaving for those reasons I just think
that Democrats have not figured out that
there is a reason why these things are
are causing you to leave I I would agree
with that my independent research would
say it's probably seven to three seven
is the conservatives so Tom's the fact
that guy when you say something
very impressive no seriously oh well
thank you very much uh my my wife got
out of college Cal State Northridge and
uh she shared teaching so she was at La
unified which for other people is a lot
is the largest school district in the
United States and it's actually two car
too large to self-manage and the
teachers union there
um very very blue but very very upset
and these teachers have been leaving and
they've been going to Phoenix and
they've been going to Riverside even and
out to areas where they feel that they
can get that they can be a teacher with
a better cost of living and so my
informal analysis of it is I'm seeing
eight to two or seven to three uh to
your question I I agree it's a little
bit about Tom I mentioned via regosa
earlier the former mayor of LA
when he was running the first time his
wife
um is a is a
teacher at LAUSD and he was asked why
don't you have your own kids at LAUSD I
remember this and the wall in front of
his house you're a big proponent of
public schools your post school choice
and he said and I quote I would never
sacrifice my kid by putting my kid in an
LAUSD School wow but I'm running for
mayor of this fine City and he did not
win because of that comment wow well at
least it was being honestly honest yeah
at least he's honest at least he's not
telling the by the way it's so funny
you're saying this we're talking about
California I'm actually really curious
and the reason why I'm asking this
question is because which one
is outwardly blue but internally they
feel safer in the red state right
because think about it socialists feel
safer in a capitalistic Society right
they don't want to leave this place if
you really feel safe for being in a
socialist society go to a socialist
country why stay in America so I think
more red is willing to leave Blue and I
don't think blue leaves red I think blue
feels safer in red while red doesn't
feel safer in blue because they're not
welcome I think you're making it more
complicated I think it's just a lot of
hypocrisy for example uh there was a
study some years ago where uh government
School teachers that's a term I prefer
instead of public school government
School teachers were asked with
school-aged kids were asked where you
put your own kids Nationwide 10 of us
have our kids in private school six
percent of black families do 49 of
Philadelphia Public School teachers with
school-aged kids had their own kids in
private schools
39 Chicago Public School teachers with
school age kids put their own kids in
private school the head of the Chicago
Teachers Union recently said that school
choice was racist her own kid is in
private school
it's just hypocrisy let me stay on this
by the way hypocrisy stats came up just
to
Brandon and I were doing this video to
see during covet top 10 highest tax
states and the bottom lowest tax states
okay during covet the top 10 highest tax
states lost 341 billion dollars of AGI
okay tax revenue the top ten lost 341
okay guess what the bottom 10 lowest tax
states gained 341 billion dollars did
you understand what just happened right
there it's a swap it's a swap it's like
you move 341 billion dollars of money
under management at Goldman to Morgan
Stanley that's exactly what happened so
covid was a great case study for us to
see what works what doesn't work my
concern right now with a state like
California do you think a California uh
uh how quickly do you think that
California could flip and if yes what
would be the reason for it to flip if I
knew the answer to that you'd be talking
to me from Sacramento I don't no I I I
liken the average voter in California to
a drug addict you got to hit rock bottom
and start and start rethinking your
votes I've never been a favor in favor
of of term limits I'm now in favor of
term limits for voters if you vote
Democrat two or three times you lose
your right to vote I'm just kidding
you're not funny I I just thought that
at some point even left-wing voters in
California would go you know what I got
to go a different way but they haven't
when I was running a
the wife of a retired Motown record
Mogul uh she's in her 80s he's in his
80s was murdered
he had armed security at his house some
guy who shouldn't have been on the
street when these lifelong criminals
broke into the house shot and killed her
a UCLA graduate student was working at a
high-end furniture store in an area of
L.A called Hancock Park where Maxine
Waters has her Mansion she was stabbed
to death by another homeless guy
and I thought maybe at this point maybe
some people in the left might rethink
their assumptions but they haven't
and Larry what do you think it is from
from like all those cities is it just
the indoctrination is so strong like if
you're living in Chicago Baltimore New
York San Francisco and you're seeing
everything is it just like listen uh
We're Not Gonna admit that this is
we're gonna stick with it because
Democrats they fall on the sword they
stay loyal to the partner it's like no
we're we're good I I think it's that
it's indoctrination it's it's that plus
a belief Republicans are just bad people
we just can't it's not that we disagree
about uh about abortion about taxes
about spending we are bad people
fundamentally bad people they've
convinced people that one well this goes
back to something we talk about all the
time and that's you know why do people
vote did they vote for personality or do
they vote for policy
I would argue that it's
overwhelmingly about personality right
so you could go the policy argument all
you want right taxes regulation but if
you don't have a charismatic candidate
on the left on the right running it like
you're never going to win it's just not
going to happen people vote on
personality I don't see it that way I
think people vote mostly on what they
perceive to be their best interest uh
often they're wrong about that but they
but they vote on what they proceed to be
in their best interests I think we have
to give the disclaimer there's never
been a more charismatic candidate than
Joe Biden oh my history
charismatic and I've never heard I've
never heard a president by the way did
you see what can you pull up the clip of
what happened to him two days ago where
even the lady is like okay uh we're done
with the event we gotta wrap it up yeah
if you can play this just a little
awkward just play this clip right here
if you could this is a must uh CTV look
at his eyes his eyes came I mean Tony
Robbins dude got nothing on this man
this guy when he speaks crowds show up
Rob isn't that the one but
Rob that's the one just play that one
there's a few that's when he was saying
that his campaign staff fought he
follows the orders of his which was the
one where the ladies in the background
says okay I got you I guess we talked
about we talked about at the conference
overall we talked about stability we
talked about making sure that the third
world the uh excuse me what's he say the
uh the the uh the southern hemisphere
had access to change it had access we it
wasn't confrontational at all thank you
everybody this men's account press
conference thanks everyone you know how
disrespectful it is just interrupt the
president yeah well I I don't think the
nursing home director had any choice
laugh all you want uh the student loan
forgiveness thing was brilliant he got a
bunch of young people voting uh in the
in the midterms who otherwise wouldn't
have voted uh the climate change stuff
that young people are fascinated by uh
it's on his side uh it's again about
policy uh and and the the hostility and
hatred against Donald Trump I've never
seen anything quite like it and so he
has all that stuff going for him yeah
the guy sit up there and says I've cut
the deficit 1.7 billion dollars
even the Washington Post called it
bottomless Pinocchio's meaning you
repeated lies so much it becomes
propaganda he says it and gets away with
it you know you talked about hitting
rock bottom and I I look for glimpses
because you know every now and then you
see a glimpse in the populace about what
they're doing and I I really thought I
saw it in um Wisconsin Michigan and
Pennsylvania in 2016 when Trump was
elected because Wisconsin and Michigan
if you want to talk about Rust Belt you
want to talk about what's going on there
Detroit once upon a time is Motor City
and yet they're making more pickup
trucks in Canada than they were in
Detroit right so much had happened in
Michigan it was it was such this is even
before
um what's her name Whitmer went kind of
lost her mind during covid
but you look at what the voter did and I
really thought is there a rock bottom
moment finally coming to to Michigan in
Detroit voted pretty blue but not as
blue as it had been and the and that
actually the state went to Trump and
Wisconsin a little less so because the
the governor Scott Walker had done a
pretty good job there but I thought I
saw some glimpses there do you see
glimpses out there where you say wow
there's a little something maybe
something's turning maybe somebody's
Rock Bottom I wish I could say that but
honestly
seven million illegal aliens from now in
the country who who were not here until
Biden comes in we've caught hundreds on
the terror watch list Lord knows how
many got away with it inflation hasn't
been this high in 40 years interest
rates now seven percent haven't haven't
been this high in years
um
people are paying five to seven hundred
dollars a month more for the same goods
and services they were paying three
years ago what does it take what's it
take
yeah I thought it's economy stupid isn't
that what Bill Clinton said the economy
is stupid what does it take who is
better off now than they were three
years ago raise your hand nobody is
nobody is yeah
show the race between hypothetical race
between Trump and buy to be within the
margin of error honestly what does it
take but here's the question though
Larry how much is attributed to Biden
versus just this is the aftermath of
covet because this if covet never
happened we wouldn't have this high of
interest rates the inflation would be
going up like Trump would have been
re-elected I agree yeah I fully agree so
I I fully every stat you just said is
absolutely correct inflation housing put
the vast majority of it is due to covet
when you agree
all I'm saying is the average voter in
my opinion should be looking at Joe
Biden and and go WTF
I'm paying all of this I'm paying 40
more for gasoline prices
um
there are seven million people in the
country illegally Lord knows how many of
them are terrorists that to me ought to
be enough it isn't and I don't know what
that is I think it's I think it's the
hostility against Republicans in general
and Donald Trump in particular and how
how brilliant is the left at demonizing
him so much that it's like we don't care
we don't give a damn about all the
problems that you just mentioned at
least it's not that orange Hitler guy in
this two-tiered system of justice ought
to be upsetting everybody are you
optimistic or pessimistic about the
future I'm cautiously pessimistic that
was that I'm I'm worried quite worried I
mean look at this two-tiered system of
justice you've got Donald Trump
let's just take the January 6 indictment
he's being indicted because essentially
his lawyers made the argument that the
vice president has more than ceremonial
duties on the first week following an
election
the same argument Democrats make at made
after 2000 when they try to decertify
Florida same argument Democrats made
after 2004 when they tried to decertify
Ohio there were 30 a house uh Democrats
plus Barbara Boxer including Benny
Thompson the chair of the January 6th
Insurrection committee all joining to
decertify Ohio because they argued that
the Debo voting machine had been
tampered with where we heard that before
2016 they challenged more States than
Donald Trump did after 2020. nobody
accused him of being election deniers
nobody prosecuted them and their lawyers
were not facing disbarment this is just
Madness and it seems to me where's the
ACLU when you need them where's the left
and and this Hunter Biden Joe Biden
stuff uh Woodward Bernstein I'm young
enough to remember that in the in the
70s they they went nuts over Richard
Nixon and Nixon didn't do it for for
greed uh he was trying to cover up the
um break-in of Watergate because he had
a bunch of uh a bunch of his aides who
got involved in that and Daniel Ellsberg
psychiatrist right minor thing and huge
and uh Woodward Woodward uh it's still
there he's still at the Washington Post
he's an executive there and Carl
Bernstein is still around where are
these guys nobody seems to care I'm
I'm Blown Away where the country is
right now I really am half the country
believes the other half is evil no
you're absolutely right and young people
when I say young people if you're in
college right now you probably don't
remember the 2000 election because
that's 23 years ago so if you're a 22
year old college student right now you
probably don't even remember 2000 Gore
pushed that case to the U.S Supreme
Court so you want to talk about election
denier it took us was it 12 or 13 weeks
to actually determine the election and
it had to get to the U.S Supreme Court
and it wasn't Bush pushing that and Tom
talk about election denying Hillary
referred to Donald Trump for the
entirety of his presidency as
illegitimate her word not mine said the
election was stolen for a word not mine
Jay Johnson is Obama's DHS secretary
testified under oath that while the
Russians tried they failed to change a
single vote tally in 2016.
two-thirds of Democrats believe
according to yukov poll that the
Russians quote change votalis close
quote to elect Donald Trump zero
evidence has changed any
a greater percentage of Democrats
believe 2016 was stolen and we feel that
way by 2020 nobody calls him election
deniers yeah
yeah and all Hillary and the DNC got was
like a hundred and seventy thousand
dollar slap on the wrist for the whole
Russian collusion dossier Hillary and
the DNC paid for the Steele dossier and
the FEC fined them yeah uh because they
characterize it as a legal expense
Donald Trump characterizes the stormy
Daniel thing as a legal expense he's
facing criminal charges by the by the
Manhattan D.A yeah it's outrageous what
is it what do you think's gonna end up
happening on Trump nothing okay so I
think he's going to get
I think he's probably going to get
nominated uh if he gets nominated he'll
get elected and he'll pardon himself
but wait a minute you also said that
Larry elderon Trump uh you said this a
few months ago I'm not sure he's
electable you said he's nominatable but
he's not electable so your positions
change in in three months
I feel more strongly now that he can win
because of the what they've done to him
uh with the uh with all these so it's
changed in three months I just feel more
strongly
um look he was a great president the
economy was rocking and rolling uh the
the borders has never been more secure
we got all the judges that we wanted up
there
built the wall uh or oil and gas
independent uh he was a great president
and he'll hopefully put those policies
back into place when he comes back yeah
I feel more strongly now than I did
before
how will he pivot to the center you know
are they famous I think Nixon was
famously said that you know you run to
the right then you pivot to the center
same with the Democrats you run to the
left right so I I fully agree that Trump
is going to be the nominee and I also
despite popular opinion I think
sleepy Joe is also going to be the guy I
think we're going to see what happens
during that debate I think he will be
the guy if he can fog up a mirror he'll
be the guy but if he's not it'll be
comedy so so when oh God forbid no no I
mean I I don't know why people feel that
somehow somebody else is going to sneak
in like that even Gavin Newsom just the
other day said yeah uh I'm not going to
run in 2024 uh Kamala Harris is uh is
next in line and I've been saying that
for months he played koi because look
the strongest part of the democratic
base are black voters
and even more strong are black female
voters and they love Kamala Harris and
they feel that when we make fun of her
cackle it's both sexist and racist they
feel that Joe Biden's given her
thankless tasks like getting to the
bottom of of illegal immigration uh they
feel she's been mistreated and if she is
perceived as having been drop kicked for
a white dude like Gavin Newsom or mayor
Pete black women won't vote Republican
they just won't vote thereby
guaranteeing whoever our nominee is he
or she will win so they can't afford to
do that and Gavin knows who knows that
that's why he never never announced but
let's stay on Trump because I think
Kamala is a non-factor but that's my
opinion I know what you just said but
how could she be a non-factor if Joe
Biden can't if Joe Biden can get across
the Finish Line as soon as he gets
across finish like he hands over the
Baton to her and she could run I just
don't think she's electable but I want
to stay on Trump if you don't mind
um so when he's going to Pivot to the
center because they're stuck with her
that's why I don't think you understand
what you you understand what he's saying
I understand completely yeah he's saying
he's gonna win then he's gonna give it
to her so she can
got behind Joe Biden South Carolina
after uh uh Bernie Sanders won the
Nevada caucuses yep for a few days he
was a front-runner they were scared to
death he's a self-described uh Democrat
socialist and they they knew he couldn't
win not to control so James Clyburn gets
off the sideline on the eve of the South
Carolina primary endorses Biden they all
fell in line he extracted a promise from
Biden that its first nominee would be a
black female
his vice president black female for a
time it looked like Dianne Feinstein
might not finished out her term in
California and Gavin Newsom publicly
said if she can't finish it out I will
nominate a black female they're all
about Blacklist the year of the black
female and they got a black female now
next in line after buying and she's
dropped kicked for a white person black
women will be livid and they will not
vote they won't vote Republican they
just won't vote well I think I think a
lot of black people are gonna black
women are gonna be upset because I don't
think home was electable but how Will
trump pivot to the center and actually
win the election because you just hit
the nail on the head as as old and
decrepit as Joe Biden is with all the
lingering issues with with Trump which I
think are a lot of uh the media and the
justice department basically
doing this
um how will he pivot to the center and
win over independent voters or even
moderate Democrats I think what he's
going to do is not a run with a female
I'm not I'm not quite sure who it'll be
but Kim Reynolds maybe of Iowa or
Christy gnome of South Dakota uh but or
maybe even Kerry Lake but it's going to
be it's going to be a female you think
that's that's how he's gonna I can't
think of anything else he can do I mean
we all know what he's about what can he
say now he can't reinvent himself he is
who he is he is what he is so I think
what he can do though is nominate a
female what about a strong black man
like Larry Elder as the VP talk to me
about that Larry I've told people if my
phone rings and Trump's on the other end
I won't let it go to voicemail
I think your phone's ringing right now
Larry but but he's not going to do that
I I that would not be a smart move I
can't bring California to him yeah uh
I'm not in the swing state and he
doesn't need to have another man he
needs he needs to have a female and
unfortunately that's the way politics
works and Larry not the goal of
conspiracy theory because Adam loves
when I I'm a coincidence you know when
they say I'm not gonna go here they're
going right there yeah it's like when
he's going right when I say it's not
about the money
because I mean as you said with the left
with 2016 with Hillary from weaponizing
the FBI and everything is against Trump
Adam made a good point that he is
obviously it's obvious he's the front
runner do you think the left has
anything up their sleeves I'm just
saying in the sense that we keep getting
warmed about pandemic tools coming from
fauci from from Biden everybody keeps
saying hey they're warning us they're
testing out the the new vaccine this new
variant to test do you think because
mind you election year Donald Trump is
probably going down as one of the best
statistic uh policy presidents ever all
of a sudden an election year a couple
months before Larry a virus comes out of
a lab that we own and they still have
zero accountability because it's still
racist it wasn't just that also 51
former intelligent officials signed a
letter saying that the hunter Biden
laptop story had all the earmarks of
Russian disinformation Nation two and a
half year collusion thing yeah using
covid to change the rules in Michigan
Wisconsin Pennsylvania uh who knows what
they're going to do exactly but but
they're going to do something some
something's up this something is
happening to keep because apparently the
game planned of keeping Joe Biden up in
the basement works so here's my here's
my question for you you you you don't
sound optimistic you said you're
cautiously pessimist right right uh
I'm I'm not sure if the voices of any
party to be cautiously pessimistic
encourage that party to want to go above
and beyond it's kind of like it's
halftime you're down three touchdowns
and a coach comes in and says guys I'm
pessimistic we're gonna lose today it's
gonna be a pretty bad loss and uh you're
all going to be you know embarrassed at
the end of it it's going to be terrible
and then boom you know Patriots come out
from down 28-3 against the Falcons and
they win the Super Bowl Jets won last
night without without well but what I'm
saying what I'm saying to you is you
know to say cautiously pessimistic and
to sound like everything is bad
everything is ugly everything is this
everything is that great well what
solution do you have for the rich
Republicans of the right for the
Christian conservatives for the
Libertarians that are also not happy
about what's going on about the business
owners about the guys that have the
money what what should be the solution
along well that's one fight against
that's why I am running I am running
because I'm America first guy believed
that taxes are too too high regulation
is too much we need to secure the
borders we need to get back to energy
Independence uh I was a very happy
camper when Donald Trump was uh was
president and um we need to work real
hard to make sure if he's a nominee he
gets back in but I'm running because
there are a number of issues that we are
not talking enough about if at all and
I've said this many times
the number one social issue in America
that nobody's talking about uh is the
epidemic of fatherlessness uh it is
particularly acute in the black
community 70 of black kids in the world
today without a father in the home
married to the mother are from 1965 when
it was uh when it was 25 percent
not 25 of white kids entered the world
today without a father in the home
married to the mother half of Hispanic
kids do it is Far and Away the number
one social problem facing this country
and the numbers are clear when you're
raised without a dead or five times more
likely to be poor and commit crime nine
times were likely to drop out of school
and 20 times when I could end up in jail
and the left isn't talking about it
because they created the problem our
side doesn't talk about it because if
you're white you're going to be called
racist if you're black you'll be called
Uncle Tom or the black face of white
supremacy but nobody but nobody's
talking about including Donald Trump
okay and so and so uh if I can get
people talking about this uh I will feel
I've given back to my country and given
back to my party I got a follow-up
question for you on that okay continue
if you have other things yeah just one
more thing when I was trying to make
this case on uh on Charlemagne and of
course they were not having it
here's the deal
um according to the CDC a young black
man aged 10 to 43 is 13 times more
likely to be murdered than a white male
same demo
Black's account for 60 of the shootings
robberies and the homicides in America
a young white man 19 and under the
number one cause a preventable death for
a young white man in that demo
is accidents like car accidents or
drownings or drug overdoses
the number one call to preventable death
for a 19 year old black male and under
is homicide almost always committed by
another young black male now if it isn't
fatherlessness please tell me unless
you're prepared to say black people are
just genetically inclined to commit more
crime tell me what it is and almost
nobody on the left when I propose that
question hasn't answered okay so the two
questions on that one let's do the
fatherless
a lot of my friends were conservative
your hero to them we're from California
so people love you admire you adore you
and hate you from the other side they
hate you obviously it's up with the LA
Times article right called you the the
what what do they call it
black face or white supremacy you can
kind of pull out the silly Times article
but then I saw I saw uh Erica D Smith or
her initials oops Yeah and then I saw
the article one that said you know you
were I think you were married in 92 and
then divorced in 94 and the story is she
wanted to have kids you didn't want to
have kids right and you've never had
kids right why a man with your kind of
values
your passion for America your
conservative values why didn't you have
kids at the time I didn't want them one
of my regrets in life is that I should
have now I'm 71 I think it's too late at
the time I didn't I mean I was I was I
mean I was 25 years old uh at one time
I'm not I'm not that age anymore and
when I was younger
I think what happened is when I was
younger I really intensely disliked my
father
I've wrote written a book about it
called dear father Dear Son two lives
eight hours my father used to spank us
really hard with a with a belt my
brothers and I both disliked him
and um
now I'm 25 years old and I sat down and
had a conversation with my dad not
having really spoken to him for almost
10 years
and I told him how much I disliked him
when I was growing up how how mean I
thought he was how angry I thought he
was for for silly reasons and my dad and
I had a conversation I thought was going
to last for five or ten minutes it ended
up lasting for eight hours wow
and during that eight hour conversation
I found out that my father never knew
his biological father my last name Elder
is not the name of his biological father
and I said I'm 25 years old now I said
well Dad who's your who was your father
he says I have no idea you never met
your dad no who's Elder Elder was the
name of a guy who was in my my life the
longest he was an alcoholic I used to
beat up my mother and when I tried to
stop him he'd beat me up my dad said
then I came home at the age of 13 and I
started calling with him my mom's then
boyfriend Elder was long gone
and the mother sided with the boyfriend
and threw my father out of the house
never to return 13 year old black boy
Athens Georgia Jim Crow South at the
beginning of the Great Depression for
the next eight hours my dad just told me
about his life he became a Pullman
Porter in the trains that's how he ended
up in California
this is before the war for the second
world war my dad was blown away you
could walk through the front door of a
restaurant
in California in LA and get served he
always had crackers and 10 cans of tuna
because he never knew in the South he'd
be able to get a meal so my dad made a
mental note maybe someday I relocated to
California Pearl Harbor my dad joined
Marines I asked him why there are any
Marines out there you know I'm going to
say two reasons that go where the action
is and my dad said I love the uniforms
Play Station on Guam
and when the war is over he goes to
Chattanooga Tennessee where he met and
married my mom to get him a job as a
cook my dad was in charge of cooking for
the colored soldiers
and he was told we don't hire he
goes to an unemployment office lady says
she went to the wrong door my dad goes
out sees colored only go through that
door to the very same lady who sent him
out my dad came with my mom and said
This is BS I'm going to La get me a job
to cook and I'll send for you so it goes
to LA
he walks around and he's told
you don't have any references my dad's I
need references to make ham and eggs and
uh my dad offered to work for free for a
reference they wouldn't even do that so
they treated him the same way in La as
they did in Chattanooga maybe a little
more polite he goes to an unemployment
office this time just one door lady says
I have nothing my dad says what time do
you open she says nine what time do you
close she says fine my dad said I'll be
sitting in that chair do you have
something my dad sat in a chair for a
whole day came back the next day sat
there for half a day she calls him up
I have something I don't know if you're
going to want it my dad said of course
I'm going to want him starting a family
what is it
and she said it's a job cleaning toilets
and the biscal brand bread my dad did
that for over 10 years took a second
full-time job cleaning at another Bread
company cleaning toilets cook for a
family on the weekend because they want
my mom to be a stay-at-home mom and he
went to night school to get his GED and
then when he got his GED he went to
night school to learn how to operate a
small restaurant the man never slept
five minutes here 15 minutes here 20
minutes here half hour here not not day
after day not week after week not month
after month but year after year which
was why he was so grouchy so as my dad
is telling me this my Dad's getting
bigger and bigger and bigger and I'm
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
and now I'm crying
and I apologize to my father for having
such a harsh view towards him and he
said there's nothing to apologize for
you just didn't know my father said just
follow the advice I've always given you
and your brothers hard work wins you get
out of life what you put into it Larry
you cannot control the outcome but you
are 100 in control of the effort and
before you moan or groan about what
someone did to you or said to you go to
the nearest mirror look at it and say to
yourself what could I have done to
change the outcome and finally my dad
said this no matter how hard you work
how good you are sooner or later bad
things are going to happen to you how
you deal with those bad things until
your mother and me if we raise the man
I was 25 years old when I had that
conversation with him for the next 35
years he and I were the best of friends
hmm I wrote a book called dear father
Dear Son two lives eight hours about
that eight hour conversation and it's
changed people's lives I get letters all
over the world from people telling me
that it changed that so so so so so so
ingrained in me was I never wanted to
have a child that felt the way I felt
about my dad and it was just in me and
uh it took a while for that to go away
by the way my brothers both married
women who had kids and they both wanted
to have kids and I had the opposite act
reaction to my dad if my brothers did
let me tell you something real quickly
about my mom my mom was born on a farm
in Huntsville Alabama
and my mom was a lifelong Democrat my
dad was a lifelong Republican and you
should have been a fly on the wall to
hear some of the arguments but nobody
called anybody a fascist nobody called
anybody a Nazi nobody said you only care
about the rich you don't care about the
poor they were able to argue
aggressively passionately but nobody
demeaned anybody and why we can't do
that in this country to me is is a real
problem and when I become president I
think I'm going to be able to change the
tone of America so we can have
discussions like this like we're having
here civilly without anybody calling
anybody a fascist or a Nazi my mother
told my brothers and me
nobody can make you feel inferior
without your permission
and so one day I'm in high school and
I'm taking a course called
African-American studies if you know me
you've never heard me use the term
African-American to describe myself I
don't I'm an American who's black I
don't like the term African-American the
name of the chorus was African-American
studies so I'm just telling you what the
name of the course was so we read a poem
by a guy named County Cullen
and it goes like this while riding
through Old Baltimore so small and full
of Glee I saw young baltimorean people
looking straight at me now I was young
and very small he was no wit bigger and
so I smiled but he poked out his tongue
and called me I saw the whole of
Baltimore from May until September of
all the things that happened there
that's all that I remember teacher was
pissed my class was all black
uh she talked about how this was going
to make the kid always feel inferior
he's going to always have a permanent
stain in his psyche he'll never feel
part of the American family
she was pissed the class was pissed I
was pissed
so I'm walking home and I knew my mom
was going to have a different reaction
to the poem although I didn't know what
it was going to be so I walked into the
house and she's frying chicken wings my
favorite and stirring a big pot of
Greens on the stove I said Mom I we
write a poem in class I want to get your
reaction to it she said what is it it
goes like this well riding through a
Baltimore so small and full of Glee I
saw a young baltimorean people looking
straight at me now I was young and very
small he was nowhere bigger and so I
smiled
but he booked out his tongue and called
me I saw the whole of Baltimore
for May until September of all the
things that happened there that's all
that I remember
my mom took the spoon out of the pot hit
it on the side and said Larry what a
darn shame he allowed something like
that to spoil his vacation how many
wings do you want no
and that's and that's and your mom's a
Democrat yeah yeah but but she was a
Kennedy type Democrat my mom by the way
because of me began voting Republican
she voted for George W bush twice and
her position was the Democratic party
left me I didn't leave the Democratic
party never changed her registration my
mom was a pro-gun person Second
Amendment person she threw up she grew
up with guns uh she was pro-life my dad
was pro-life my mom uh strong National
Security
and she thought Democrats just became
just crazy
so I think that's how Robert Kennedy
feels I think about his party as well
right now Robert Kennedy Jr
Larry you just went straight to Robert
Kennedy but man what you just said the
last five ten minutes now explains
there's there's a lot of men that and
I'd be curious to know what you would
say to this you're now you said you're
70 or 71 71. okay so you're so April
27th when's your birthday April 27th
yeah 71 of course you haven't had kids
you wish you would have had kids and in
I respect you for saying it now because
that's for wisdom we can borrow wisdom
from somebody like you who's got a few
decades on us what do you say to men who
are in their 20s late 20s Courier guys
or 30s or 40s who are like you know what
you know I I also don't want to have
kids I also don't want to have kids
because there's too much responsibility
I don't have a good father figure I
didn't have a good relationship with
them what do you say to them you're
going to regret it
that's what I'd say to him
um I have friends now peers who have uh
kids and they've got grandkids and I've
never seen
a man more joyful than when he's with
his grandkids
and I don't have grandkids I don't have
kids
um
I think you're missing out
what about however however it isn't um
for everybody my girlfriend never wanted
to have kids when I first met her I
thought she was saying it because she
thought that's what I wanted her to say
[Music]
um
one of my close friends is Dennis Prager
Dennis Prager has always often argued
that you are not a fully developed human
being until you've had kids until you've
had that experience
and I've been on the same station with
Dennis Prager for years and every year
he'd have his dad come in from New York
and his dad would talk about various
things
and one time Dennis gets up to use the
restroom this is during a break and Mr
Prager is there with me Dennis's dad
I see Mr Prager Dennis says that if you
don't have kids you're not fully formed
as an adult because it always bothered
me since I didn't have kids
and Mr Prager said I don't feel that way
at all
I feel that you can just observe other
people and have your own life
experiences from other people there's no
reason why you have to have kids if you
don't want to have kids it's ridiculous
to say that you would not be a police
later on when his dad left what his dad
said
so typical father you know I remember
one time Dudley Shepherd of the Hills
you know who Dudley Rutherford is the
the pastor from L.A I used to have a
radio show with kkla KLA called save in
America I used to be right next to
Prager salt and Glendale on that New
York Life right next to the New York
Life building right but uh Dudley used
to bring his father and his dad would
always undermine what Dudley would say
it was so funny you say look my son
doesn't know what he's talking about
here's how this works and it was a
interesting Dynamic father-son
relationship let's let's continue let's
continue on this um you know issue with
uh presidential uh uh issues you're
running on I did not see you at
Milwaukee we were at the debate yeah and
I know you're talking about I was in
Milwaukee you were in my home I was in
the city of Milwaukee I was not a debate
because the RNC at the last minute uh
shafted me I mean I met all the debate
criteria forty thousand individual
donors U.N Suarez I believe
Suarez I don't know about his situation
I just know about mine uh I I hit the 40
000 individual donors
our 200 had to come from 20 different
states we had 237 different states I had
to submit three polls where I was at one
percent or better I did that I get a
phone call from Ronald McDaniel the
chair of the GOP and David bossy the
debates are and they tell me I'm not
eligible for the debate because one of
the one of the polls I submitted uh is
not going to be used I said which one
Rasputin why
it's affiliate with the Trump campaign I
said well assuming that's true why is it
my problem and they said any poll
affiliated with any candidate can be
used by any other candidate Rasmussen
then put on a statement and said Trump
is not affiliated with our campaign with
our poll had nothing to do with our poll
there's no reason why Elder can't use it
so even if I even if I had picked up the
phone and called and rasputed before I
submitted the poll and said by the way
are you affiliated with Trump they would
have said no
then I submitted a fourth poll
and Ronald McDaniel said you submitted
it too late what's true I submitted it
after their deadline
one I didn't know I needed to submit
another one but more importantly they
finished their polling before the
deadline they didn't release the results
until after the deadline but they
finished the polling before the deadline
so there was enough wiggle room where in
my opinion had they wanted me up there
they could have allowed me up there my
lawyer is the former chair of the
Federal Election Commission
and he argues that because the RNC
failed to apply the criteria fairly to
Elder what they did in effect was give
an in-kind contribution to the eight
people who are up there in their debate
stage and the value of that in-kind
contribution based on how much Fox
charges for a spot is almost 100 million
dollars and if you don't put Elder up
there we gave them until two o'clock on
the debate day to change their mind
we're going to file a complaint with the
FEC well two o'clock came and went and
we've now filed that complaint
now the next step is to get on the
debate stage on the 27th of this month
in Reagan Library yeah three percent in
three different polls plus 50 000
individual donors as for the 50 000
individual donors that's not going to be
a problem but the three percent is and
two days ago we launched a 500 000 ad
campaign to try and get my numbers up so
it's going to be a coin toss later out
of uh I'm pretty sure you saw it that
the first debate if you had to choose if
you if you weren't even in the in on in
the race if you had to pick out of all
of them I'm pretty sure you saw who
would you who would you put at the top
who won who who won that night Donald
Trump I'm serious I'm serious by not
going that was smart not to go
um I thought and I and I felt this way
when I ran for governor
I did not say a single negative thing
about any of my Republican Rivals not
one time uh I shot right to the top and
it wasn't because I was a front runner I
didn't expect that but I was I felt that
the target was Gavin Newsome remember it
was a two-part deal the first part is do
you want this man recalled
it doesn't matter what happens on the
second part if he isn't recalled and
every single time somebody said what do
you think about John Cox John Cox was
the guy that ran against gavinism the
first time and he also ran as a
replacement candidate I said it's not
about John Cox it's about what what
Gavin Newsom did by shutting down
California and the more severe way than
anybody else is about people leaving
California for the very first time in
170 years it's about cry it's about
homelessness it's about the awful school
budget it's about how bad our schools
are doing it's about the fact that we
are under we have an underfunded pension
liability of 1.5 trillion dollars in
California
if the others had said that instead of
saying well Elders this elder is that
Elder's at I think the first part might
have passed so I feel the same way about
this debate
we ought to all come together meaning
Republicans and make sure that Biden
doesn't get four more years the idea
that we can't at least agree not to call
Donald Trump an insurrectionist as one
of them did up there you got to be
kidding me
We can't agree on the borders on on uh
on on crime on this defund the police
nonsense we ought to be talking about
that and the fact that Republicans were
taking shots at each other in my opinion
that Donald Trump won yeah oh yeah and
calling the the instructions I don't
know if you guys saw yesterday Kamala
Harris did a speech about 9 11 and she
compared January 6th to Pearl Harbor and
9 11 is Despicable yeah it was
ridiculous the second debate that Trump
may or may not go to uh a do you think
he should go and B why do you think that
that even the desantises certainly the
penses of the world the crisis of the
world even Nikki Haley are not going to
coalesce around Trump you know I I'd be
the biggest hypocrite in the world if I
were to tell Donald Trump he should go
to the second debate or even the first
one I didn't go to any of my debates
when I was running for governor they had
about a half a dozen of them and I said
the same thing I just said to you I said
there's no point enough to get into a
circular firing squad and giving Gavin
Newsom video he's going to use against
whoever it is who's the front runner and
that's exactly what what when my opinion
happened
um
look Chris Christie uh is probably the
only one up there that I think
I I would feel
I would feel I feel that any of the
eight people up there is a better
president than Joe Biden with the
exception of Chris Christie the the fact
that he's referred to Donald Trump as an
interactionist uh and can't understand
that what's happening to our country
with this two-tier system of justice is
much more important than your hostility
towards Donald Trump I don't understand
that what are your thoughts on vivec I
know that you've said hi praise about
him he also said that he stole a line
from you about the number one problem he
did what are his chances
look the 800 pound Grill in the room is
is Donald Trump he's not going anywhere
um you know unless he has a health
problem or something like that I can't
imagine that uh that he's not going to
get the nomination right now
um I have a problem with anybody who
stands up there and says quote I'm the
only one up here who's not bought and
paid for close quote which is what he
said Vivek said really
Tim Scott's button paid for really
37 years old never run for office before
you're the only one who's not bought and
paid for I thought that was a bit much
regarding him stealing my line
here's here's the back story
on one of our you know we've been in in
Iowa New Hampshire many times I've seen
him speak many times heard me speak many
times
she's never once referred to the
epidemic of fatherlessness
so right before the first debate he
comes up to me
at one of our events I forget where
he said can we can I talk to you
privately I said sure step into my
office we went over to the side a little
bit and he said if you don't make the
debate will you endorse me
and I said I cannot promise that I can
tell you this if I don't make the debate
say something to the effect of my friend
Larry Elder can't be up here however he
has brought to the Forefront the issue
of the epidemic of fatherlessness and I
sued him for having done that
as you know he said part of that but did
not give me any attribution I'm okay
with the fact that he's raised the issue
that's much more important than getting
attribution but he did say he was going
to do that and then didn't do it
by the way by the way for decades I have
been saying we've got a country to save
guess who said that during the debate
Nikki Haley quote we've got a country to
save
just saying so it sounds like you're
going to be sort of the president yes I
was I was there in spirit yeah if not in
body what is this Rob
uh this is a clip of Larry talking about
the fatherless episode go ahead and play
that play that
epidemic of fatherlessness so part of
the problem is we also have a federal
government that pays single women more
not to have a man in the house than to
have a man in the house contributing to
an epidemic of fatherlessness
Larry you might have to just do the
voiceover first yeah
this is the GOP Lincoln
look I think Vivek is all over spoken I
think Vivek is an absolute stud but this
isn't the first time
stealing lines he obviously his first
line was you know I'm a skinny little
kid with a funny last name he took that
from Obama Obama but you know they say
like we stand on the shoulders of giants
can it just be seen as like look I'm
just using what works right and can you
blame him somebody once said the
originality is the art of concealing
your source so and Joe Biden as you know
he had at least one or two campaigns to
go supernova because he stole from other
people didn't didn't give them
attribution well even Donald Trump took
make America great again from Ronald
Wayne Reagan right yeah so I mean some
of these things are just duplicatable
yeah
you're right okay well Agree to Agree
though yeah what are your thoughts on
RFK
uh I I think he's uh got some
interesting ideas I mean he's not your
typical Democrat but he is a Democrat he
is uh I've not heard him say anything
about taxes being too high regulations
being too high I've never heard him say
anything about we should be rolling back
this March towards Single Payer on
Healthcare uh so he's still a Democrat
although he's a much more rational one
than some of the others he was opposed
to the lockdowns
uh he um said that he doesn't believe
any additional gun control law will will
do anything about gun violence although
he does support a assault weapons ban so
he's a little more rational than the
average Democrat but he's still a
Democrat
he's still a democracy still Democrat
and you saw what they did with New
Hampshire pretty much there's nothing he
can do to be nominated to to win
anything they pretty much lock them out
so if that's the case why is he still
campaigning
you have to ask him I mean I think
people run for different reasons I mean
I'm realistic about my opportunity to
become president I think that uh it's a
long shot but I'm running for the issues
I mentioned you know to talk about
homelessness and father listen to
further and the lie that America
systemically races that's getting people
killed
um and I don't think our side by the way
effectively deals with that well enough
um
it's not just driving nonsense like
reparations I mentioned that which I
consider to be the extraction of money
from people never slave owners to be
given to people who never slaves is
driving stuff like uh uh race-based
preferences and and Dei is getting
people killed it's called the Ferguson
effect or the George Floyd effect and
that's phenomenon of cops pulling back
all over America for fear of being
accused of systemic racism as a result
in city of the city of the city there
are lots of people who are dead who
otherwise wouldn't be dead if the police
were doing their normal proactive
policing and I don't think that our side
I mean Republican side
is calling enough attention to the
Damage Done by this lie
look at the George Floyd riots or the
black lives matter riots that took place
and protests in in May of of 2020 lasted
four months most deadly a protests in
the history of America 35 people killed
2 000 police officers injured about two
billion dollars in property damage
insured property damage maybe another
billion or two in uninsured property
damage all because of an assumption a
narrative that would happen to George
Floyd had to do with his race
now the thing was televised remember and
the lead prosecutor was a black man and
he never once said that what happened to
George Floyd had anything to do with his
race in fact in his opening statement
he took pains to say the police in
general were not on trial the
Minneapolis PD in general was not on
trial in fact he praised them he said
this individual cop Derek Chauvin is on
travel what he did he didn't do to
George Floyd yet all these people in the
streets
on the assumption that what happened to
George Floyd had to do with his race now
I think if you were to to ask most of
the people there were 200 cities ahead
protests millions of people in the
streets
I think if you were to ask most of these
people to describe their political
ideology most of them would probably say
that I'm either very liberal or liberal
there's a website called policemack.com
this is important
people who were self-described as very
liberal were asked how many unarmed
black men did the police kill in 2019
one half of uh of the self-described
very liberal people 50 of them thought
the police killed 1 000 unarmed black
men in 2019.
eight percent thought to kill ten
thousand of those who were
self-described as liberal
39 thought they killed one thousand five
percent thought they killed ten thousand
according to the Washington Post
database it was 12. that's the gap
between what people think is going on
versus what is going on that's what
happens to your mentality to be fair not
12 000 or 1200 12 well Washington Post
database
and in fact the police kill more unarmed
white people every year than to kill
unarmed blacks and there are video of
the police mishandling manhandling
mistreating unarmed white people nobody
cares I urge people to Google Kelly
Thomas Fullerton California a few years
ago
uh literally uh there's three or four
cops beating up this homeless guy
two of them were tried found not guilty
one was uh one that charges dismissed
against him
almost nine ten minutes of video almost
as long as George Floyd there's another
one called Tony Tempa t-i-m-p like Paul
a Dallas Texas homeless guy uh mentally
ill cops beat him up
I can't breathe I can't breathe you said
all that maybe 13 minutes of video
Dallas Texas a white guy nobody nobody
cares and my point is
giving you the false impression that the
police are killing unarmed black people
when in fact it is rare for the police
to kill anybody let alone an unarmed
black person and by the way unarmed does
not mean not dangerous Michael Brown was
unarmed but his DNA was found on the on
the officer's gun he had done a strong
arm robbery just just uh minutes earlier
so just because you're unarmed doesn't
mean you're not perceived as dangerous
but it's rare for the police to kill
anybody let alone an unarmed black
person but but the people in the streets
as I said from these numbers have no
blooming idea how how infrequent this is
the closest comparison I can make to
this the following and I'm curious to
get your thoughts on this
so
um why does one story get more momentum
than the other one why does the one
story uh Black's experience in them
versus white kids it's the narrative
we'll give you a recent example here in
Florida that Jacksonville races killed
those three black guys here in Florida
and Joe Biden uh made a comment and not
only did he make a comment he said
uh
silence in the face of hate like this is
complicit
you're being implicit
about three months ago Tulsa Oklahoma
black guy gets a gun if you are hearing
this for the first time this is my point
black guy gets a gun walks into a white
guy
pulls out the gun shoots him in the back
of the head and kills him goes to
another area of Tulsa Oklahoma he's
another white guy pulls out the gun
shoots him in the back of the head and
kills him admits he did it because they
were white
Biden didn't say a damn thing
he didn't say a damn thing about that
because it doesn't Advance the agenda
and by the way most homicide
is same race homicide most whites were
killed or killed by other whites most
blacks were killed are killed by other
blacks however every year there are a
handful of black white homicides out of
the say 20 000 homicides about 750 of
them are black white white black 500
white people are killed by blacks even
though blacks are just 13 of the
population 250 blacks are killed by
whites even the whites are 60 in the
population so blacks are killing twice
as many uh whites as the other way
around
most people have no idea about that stat
I'll give you another one forget about
homicides this is violent crime between
blacks and whites other than homicide
attempted murder rape assault with a
weapon roughly half a million such
instances every single year 85 to 90
percent is a black white victim only 10
to 15 the other way around most people
aren't aware of that now if some white
guy white Republican said you know we
have an epidemic of black Supremacy uh
in America as Biden said about white
supremacy at Howard
if a white guy said that we would
probably call him a race hustling
demagogue and he'd be denounced but
Biden can go to Howard University
and tell these graduating students just
a few months ago the number one problem
facing the Homeland is white supremacy
and nobody says a damn thing he is being
every bit a race hustling demagogue is
Al Sharpton but nobody said a word why
I think it's Republicans nothing scared
to Republican more than a left-wing
person calling him or her a racist they
run from that which is one of the
reasons I believe the Democratic Party
of the Republican party never really
cared that much about me being on the
debate stage I say this kind of stuff
makes them feel uncomfortable
Republicans are trying to reach out to
Black voters
and they fear if they talk about
fatherlessness that black women will
perceive them as being demeaned that
somehow you're undermining the hard work
that black females by themselves are are
doing raising these kids uh you're not
doing anything of the kind but I think
Republicans are afraid the reaction will
be the same way uh if Republicans start
talking about the kind of stuff racially
that I'm talking about the fact that
black people kill more white people than
the other way around I think they feel
that the media and the left will jump
all over them
it's it's it's no fun being called an
Uncle Tom it's no fun being called the
black face the white supremacy uh and
for a white person to be called a racist
that's no fun either so they'd rather
not talk about it do you think it's
still Democrats against Republicans
Republicans against them Democrats or do
you think it's establishment versus
anti-establishment meaning do you think
that distinction has been made to the
American voter to say look you're either
voting for a establishment Republican
candidate you're voting for an
establishment Democratic candidate or
you're voting for an anti-establishment
Democratic candidate or
anti-establishment republican candidate
I I guess I don't see it that way at all
I think the divide in this country is
between the left wokism uh uh the
perception that America is still a
country of racism of sexism of
homophobia uh and those who believe in
hard work accountability and personal
responsibility that's to me is the
Divide uh Democrats Hollywood media
Academia big Tech they're all on one
side and people that are hard working
they just want to get by and want
government off their backs or on the
other side I was watching a debate one
time between uh Debbie Wasserman Schultz
the chair of the DNC and Ryan
priebus the chair of the RNC
and uh I'm this is a live debate so I
was texting uh reince priebus he didn't
see my text it didn't respond to it but
Debbie Wasserman Schultz said
I want to know
that my party has my back
and I texted him and I said I want to
know which party will get government off
my back I think that's a divide but but
but okay so that you know there are
people that want to have government
control you from both sides though left
and right so this is why what I'm trying
to say is
you ever read the book Blue Ocean
strategy or no okay so Blue Ocean
strategy is a book about how to uh not
directly compete against your
competition I think Republicans are
completely Miser Mark they all sound the
same and they're all screwing it up in
my opinion I could be completely wrong
but this book talks about you got to
increase decrease eliminate create so
you got to increase a little bit of
something you got to decrease a little
bit of something you got to eliminate
something that everybody is doing or you
gotta create something new so for
example yellowtail uh is a wine company
that was directly competing against
other wine companies that were getting
destroyed
blue ocean idea comes out yellowtail
says instead of competing against wine
drinkers we are cheap wine we're not
going to beat these guys yellowtail goes
and competes against beer drinkers to
get yellowtail to be sold at bars etc
etc yellowtail goes from selling I don't
know you know how many cases per year to
48 million cases per year it's been
success story and they blow up bro and
they become a whole different company so
when you're in a red ocean everyone's
stealing from each other stealing votes
from each other stealing all this stuff
from each other versus the go-to Blue
Ocean there's no other sharks here have
your own Market Republicans keep
fighting the same fight and they keep
getting their asses handed to them it's
the same thing the way they're
presenting the argument is as Democrats
against Republicans is this this this
that versus no it's the people that want
to make decisions for you the
establishment versus the
anti-establishment I have difficulty
accepting the premise um
this is not a product this is not a a
but it is though it's it's ideas it's
it's what will make your life better
for example one of the things that I
argue and would have mentioned had I
been on the debate
both Republicans Democrats talk about
the size of government Republicans say
the government's too big and they want
tax cuts there's one candidate that has
a two percent reduction in the size of
government every year something like
that
government's going to get bigger and
bigger no matter who's President unless
we do something radical and that radical
is this
we need an amendment to the Constitution
to fix spending to a certain percentage
of the GDP otherwise it gets bigger and
bigger whether Ronald Reagan is
President whether George W bush is
President whether W is President whether
George Walker Bush is President where
the Trump is President largely because
the biggest driver of our budget are the
so-called entitlements even Barack Obama
and Bill Clinton use the word
unsustainable to describe them but
nothing happens if you run promising
you're going to reform entitlement
programs You're Gonna Lose election
because the other side is going to
accuse you of not caring about the poor
the stick the elderly the only way to do
the kinds of reforms and the kinds of
cuts
that's necessary is a law that's forcing
the politicians to do that and the only
way you're going to do that is to amend
the Constitution and so as the president
with my bully pulpit I will be
explaining to American people
particularly young voters that these
programs are not going to be there for
you unless there's serious dramatic
reform and it's not Pie in the Sky the
the Constitution has been amended on
average every 10 years and all you have
to do is make the case of the American
people and nobody's doing that not Trump
not the sad it's not anybody
it's been amended 27 times I think that
if the numbers that 27. so my point is
to to your to your argument I don't look
at it that way I think that we need to
explain to the American people why my
policies are better than this guy's
policies why I'm more likely to have an
economy that thrives than this guy why
I'm more likely to be able to secure
borders in this guy and you've put
together a a set of policies and issues
that a voter can vote for
that vote will vote for well I would say
the the only reason I'm making this
argument is because if you think about
why Trump did well in 2016. his message
was not like the rest of you guys
everybody had the same message every
candidate had the same message oh we're
going to do this everybody's saying the
same Marco Rubio sounded the same as Ted
Cruz sounded the same as you know
Huckabee sounded the same as you know a
car you name them all everybody said the
same here's a guy that came and said
I've given money to everybody here okay
there's a reason why everybody's
clapping for this guy Jeb Bush is
because they didn't let me come in here
all the people here are his donors all
the booing they're all the donors that's
right it's true right these guys all
gave money to him he took money from
them Jeb goes that laugh is a weak laugh
and his messaging I think Trump won in
16 because Trump had a blue ocean
everybody on the stage was fighting the
same fight except for one guy and he
crushed everybody everybody was like you
know what man what angle do we take in
Cisco he has given me money I can't take
that argument he did say this he did say
that and then today even with RFK you
know aside from them bullying him the
way they have why is RFK getting
momentum actually think about it why is
RFK getting so much momentum
because maybe the American people are
sick of the establishment and the
anti-establishment message the last two
elections is resonating with people one
the way Trump did it Wonder way you know
in covet which was catastrophic what
happened with Kobe so take that part of
that in the today's election RFK if you
were to say the guys that are getting
momentum on two sides take the guys that
are getting momentum onto both sides
even set aside Trump whether you like
him or not vivec is one of them RFK is
one of them both of their messages is an
anti-establishment message
and everybody else's message is pretty
much an established message Nikki Haley
is an established message Chris Christie
is an establishment message Pence is an
establishment message I you know who
else you want me to give you everybody
is an establishment message except for
two candidates Vivek and RFK and they're
gaining momentum I think Trump also came
in as somebody who was in your face uh
he talked about political uh correctness
uh he was able to in a very skillful way
demean his opponents one after another
after another I think people find him
funny find him entertaining uh
charismatic I've never seen a politician
like that I I think he's um a unique a
unique person I've never seen any
anything quite like it good perfect
let's go to the last example of a guy
that ran like Trump but didn't have a
personality can you think of the and who
got 19 20 no one thought it was going to
happen it would cost another guy that
was supposed to be a two-term president
that became a one-term president that in
his documentary there was one guy he
didn't want to comment on and I was Ross
Perot George was senior didn't want to
talk about Ross for in his documentary
when the award Perot came out he did not
want to he says I don't want to talk
about that I don't want to talk about
that so what happened with pearl how did
Pearl speak he wasn't funny he was
boring actually he was funny now why now
why are they doing that now I'm gonna
get on the hood I'm gonna look at it
right now I'm gonna look at it and put
it back down that's gonna take care of
that I'm not gonna sound about it he was
hysterical but he wasn't Trump he didn't
have Trump's personality and that's the
damn he wasn't he didn't have Trump
but what did he have but he also ran as
an independent he had a message
Independents don't win they just don't
win but it's not what I'm it's the point
well Trump was an independent who ran as
a republican yeah but he ran as a party
totally agree so rosborough made a
mistake running as a as a independent he
could have ran as a republican could
have been a different story he could
have ran as a party to represent that he
would had a maybe a different story but
the point I'm making here is all I'm
interested in as a business owner as a
guy that studies the markets to see
right who has an advantage on the way
they Market themselves I look at the
santis and I said here's a guy with a
phenomenal resume
who has a better resume after covert
than him nobody
there's not a single governor with a
better resume than him right after covet
what happened with his messaging doesn't
doesn't connect he he sounds like
everybody else again I I think you're
making it much more complicated than it
is I think there's a phenomenon known as
Donald J Trump the likes of which nobody
has ever seen this guy never even ran
for office let alone held office wasn't
a general came out of nowhere he used to
be a Democrat then he was an independent
then he became Republican he had a
almost 100 name recognition from uh The
Apprentice uh there's just been nothing
like him I'm shocked that Rhonda sandis
is not doing better but when you compare
him to Donald Trump I'm sorry it's like
it's like Larry Holmes
he comes after Muhammad Ali I'm sorry
Larry Holmes was a great fighter but
when you come after Muhammad Ali that's
a big Shadow and so
the status is in Donald Trump's Shadow
right now and and when Donald Trump if
he gets elected again he becomes lame
duck the next day I think the front
runner in 2020 uh eight will be will be
Ron DeSantis you think so yeah
you think so oh yeah Florida Florida he
he stood down covid he stood down wokism
um uh he got reelected with 20 uh he he
took Miami-Dade County uh he looks great
uh he's a war hero uh great wife a
cancer survivor what's not to like it's
just not your time it's Donald Trump's
time sorry is Mega gonna support him
after him essentially going after Trump
I think so
but that's a that's a long way away I
mean that's a real far down the road but
I really think that we just have to
recognize that Donald Trump I've never
seen a one-term president hold on to the
party like this when uh when Jimmy
Carter lost he couldn't get a table at
Fatburger when George when George
Herbert Walker Bush lost nobody talked
to him this guy lost he's a one-term
president and he maintained his grip
over the party I've never seen anything
like it so and I've been watching
politics since I was eight years are you
a sports guy yeah okay you ever seen the
movie Billy Bean the Money Ball I did
okay we watched a movie all the time my
favorite movies he's the only guy that I
brought three times to speak at my
different events wow is he still the
Oakland uh GM I think he is I don't know
if he went anywhere but he got the offer
from Boston but he never did never took
it yeah so when you meet him you know so
this guy was a five tool player right he
was supposed to be the next you know
whatever whatever there's a part in a
movie where he asked the question of a
uh is it Noah is the actor's name uh
Jonah Hill Jonah Hill he says so let me
ask you a question after we I left I
know you searched me and I know you
looked at my numbers would you have
picked me number one draft pick he says
yeah I would have he said stop
bullshitting me tell me the truth where
would you have picked me he said I would
have picked you in the ninth round yeah
he says and you would have gone to
Stanford and he takes a drink and he
puts it down he says got it well pack
your bags come down here I just signed
you I bought you from the Cleveland
Indians right right okay so here's
here's all I'm going Jonah uh the guy
that plays who does he play by the way
in the movie is he playing
right so and he comes in he's saying all
these years you know we're watching 61
two days ago the whole story with Roger
Marissa Mickey man on the owner of the
Yankees are like I brought you to the
bombers I don't carry or 260 batting
average hit the Homer swing for defense
that's why we brought you here right
back in the days baseball was about what
who can hit the home runs who can get
the eyeballs who can fill up the arena
everything changed once you know podesta
you know on base percentage all this
other stuff I think
I think you guys are are are so been in
this world for so long in the police and
I keep saying you guys I mean people who
are in the political side I don't want
to put you as you guys but you're part
of media you've been around for a long
time hell you gotta star in the freaking
Hall of Fame you know on the uh
Hollywood Walk of Fame so
I think that world you are so used to
saying the same lines the same things
the same things every three four years
that nobody has sat there and challenged
the establishment of media opinions
radio you know whatever no one's
challenge you guys to say I don't think
you're looking at the right categories
of who to choose as a candidate I think
you keep looking at the same old same
old way of selecting candidates and I
think what Trump is doing to that world
he's shocked the hell out of everybody
to say okay what used to matter is not
what matters today what matters today is
very different let's look at a golf
score of candidates to put up there to
look at and then realize nope this guy's
not going to do it he just doesn't have
the X Factor he doesn't have to follow
him he doesn't have this he doesn't have
this he doesn't have that the score here
golf scored the number one guy if I had
more time on my hands right and I wasn't
running nine companies I would hire I'm
being serious with you right now I would
hire 10 analysts bring them men put the
last 500 candidates that we've had
them's right independent everything get
every one of their scoring based on 40
different categories then eliminate 10
of the categories the bottom 10 then go
30 then go eliminate bottom 10 they go
20 then eliminate bottom 10 they go top
10 and then I would go based on the top
10 most important areas to select a
candidate look at a golf score and say
you know what look at this look what
trend we notice this guy did this
because it is that guy no this guy's not
gonna win that guy's not gonna win not
saying there's some people that do this
out there but I think you act like it's
mathematical it's not it's not but I
think it is remember in the in the in
the movie
Moneyball yeah he said you think you
know but you don't he had all these
coaches there you don't who saw Donald
Trump coming nobody did yeah nobody did
who thought Joe Biden coming in 2020
nobody did not until Clyburn got behind
him
this is unpredictable I mean
I never thought Donald Trump was was
going to get the nomination until
well that's a different story because
you're talking about the Astros winning
the World Series here's the deal I'm at
home when he comes down the escalator
yeah
and he says Mexicans uh they're they're
rapists or this that the other oh my God
oh my God this is going to be one of the
shortest campaigns in here the next day
I'm in an area of L.A called Sunland
which is a blue collar mostly white area
and I'm I'm at this restaurant called
Coco's which is like a Denny's I'm at
the bar having my vegetarian breakfast
the bacon eggs and hash browns
guy walks up to me are you are you Larry
Elder I said yeah he said what are you
doing here I said I'm here on business
he said what do you think about what my
guy said last night
I said my guy he said yeah Donald Trump
and the guy by the way was a painter as
a house painter yeah and I said what did
you think of him he said it's about time
somebody spoke for me and he walked away
wow another guy comes up to me five
minutes later you Larry oh yeah what are
you doing here I'm here uh what did you
what do you think about what Trump said
like what did you think about what Trump
said last night man it's about time
somebody stood up and first little
people
I was there for 45 minutes and that kind
of conversation repeated itself over and
over and over again two guys were
Hispanic one guy looked like he was
Asian American and I went on the air
that day
and I said I recounted what I just told
you and I said I've never seen a
republican connect with regular people
like that's in Toronto Reagan this guy's
going to get the nomination he's going
to become the next president United
States yeah and nobody was saying it at
the time okay so my point is
who saw that coming even CNN msnb Hee
Haw with as I call it they kept putting
them up there because they're ready
there is a great category for that the
ratings went up yeah but they thought of
him as a joke okay Ariana Huffington
went on television and said we're
covering him and Huffington Post in the
entertainment section because he's not
being I would create that as a category
on the golf score I would create that as
a gift so here's what I wrote based on
what you just said so let's have some
fun together all right all right number
one Moneyball okay remember the scene
where all the old Scouts are like I like
this one guy who would want to have his
girlfriend at best as a six you should
never have a starter that's a six as a
girlfriend no you didn't have these are
all the old guys in their 60s and 70s
how you should recruit and then this guy
said this is a beautiful Square
beautiful Square yeah
why isn't he hit well he's going to
learn how to hit so we're going to teach
him that's the part of the time
the scouts thought they knew what they
were talking about because they've been
in that world for so long right okay and
then a new player shows up a new guy
Jonah Hill deeper that's the same we got
to look in a completely different way
I'll give you the other one one of the
things I would put as a category
is this is what I visualize a lot of
candidates choosing their presidential
election you know what they're going to
campaign on here's what they do
let me role play and tell me if I'm
wrong okay and call me out you're wrong
I love it
let me finish my point one quick thing
though you mentioned vivec yeah as as a
non-establishment yeah
he's at five percent okay six percent
yeah come on but no he's at six percent
because he's going against the number
one establishment guy that's what I'm
talking about no that's not what you're
talking about that's the elephant in the
room you don't understand my point no
you don't don't no no you're not
understanding my point the Vivek is
following the Playbook of trump and he's
at five percent because there is a trump
what if there was no Trump take Trump
out but there is no no I understand that
but because the guy ahead of him is a
bigger anti-establishment candidate
which is attractive to people in America
but the fantas has higher numbers than
Vivek and according to you DeSantis is a
established because the sentence a year
ago you had no clue who the guy was
you've known the sentence uh Vivek you
didn't know a year ago who he was he was
not even a your your argument is you got
to get somebody who who's
non-non-traditional I'll give you
honestly no I will mine Vivek is that
way you're not he's number three the
next guy is in your view an
establishment guys Mr Hollywood Walk of
Fame let me push back okay as the guy
that's 30 years Junior just to give you
a different perspective okay I could be
wrong and I'm very comfortable with that
you are hear me out yeah you are you are
by the way this has been the history for
the longest time 70 year olds thinking
40 year olds are wrong all right and a
40 year olds kind of tend to disrupt a
little bit that's kind of and then a 40
year olds think they know it all 20 year
olds disrupt with social media we have
to pay attention to these types of guys
so watch this
so you're saying uh you know Vivek
doesn't have that going on yep because
Vivek would be missing one massive
massive massive category on the golf
score what is that online Persona TV
personality you don't have it started
too late way too late Trump's been doing
it for 50 years okay one of the biggest
thing for me an anti-establishment guy
would be your online your social Persona
your TV persona for how long whether
it's not necessarily a cue score
following you know viability today you
know stories today all that other stuff
so that vivec does not have that doesn't
work in his favor okay two would be
charm and selling the scientist doesn't
have charm and selling Vivek has that
okay the scientist is more policies and
as much as we want to put policies at
the top I think policies is maybe top
five maybe top three I think there's
things way more important than policies
when it comes down to getting eyeballs
now Biden I totally agree but that's a
Black Swan event that's not a typical
traditional season pandemic it's a very
different season I don't even think it's
that I think he was bringing up Clyburn
let's just call Biden the Astros case
because yeah because they did the
Democratic DNC I think we all agree
decided to cheat so let's take Biden off
the side and just say well hey they
cheated it and they picked them isn't
that correct they decided to to dig cap
Bernie Sanders because they didn't think
he could win right they didn't like they
didn't like the way it was working out
in the whoops Democratic process through
elections and primaries state by state
and they just decided I had one of the
things yeah can I wanted to thank you
one other thing that kind of helps out
here that if you put Ross Perot that if
you put fivec who's a junior junior that
if you put Trump had this thing called
Fu money okay they don't need so now
you're agreeing thank you Larry we are
converting a little bit no no no you're
not yes I am I'm agreeing with you that
Donald Trump is a unique specie he is is
that the name of a pack he's got Fu
money he's got 100 name recognition he's
got a personality like nobody that I've
ever seen and Vivint doesn't have one of
the four
let's take a look at this does the
centers have a big social media
following no okay does the santis have
charm no no does he have policies yes
yes does he have a few money no no do
you see it's one out of four you
understand the point I'm making to you
the game is changing it's called Blue
Ocean strategy Moneyball two stars
this is the point I'm trying to make but
the whole thing Trump is an absolute
anomaly we've never seen anything like
him he's got checked check check the
policy thing is almost irrelevant and I
think a lot of his policies we're good I
have one fifth one that is irrelevant
it's not irrelevant that's why he's a
republican Republicans stand for strong
borders they stand for strong National
Security they stand for Law and Order
stand for low regulations so that's
assumed but I wrote one additional Point
here Mr Elder the guy that listens to
you more than you listen to me okay I've
listened to you you're the guy okay that
we follow you are the man okay man you
are the man I agree with that yeah
oh there's by the way we don't have we
have to agree on that we've agreed on
that for for years yeah okay but here's
the part the other thing that he does
which I like that parole did
and that Trump did and that Vivek did to
Father listeners bringing it in but I'll
tell you what it is it's creating an
issue that no one is talking about okay
Trump came up and said the wall border
rapist drugs you're like whoa whoa no
one's talking about that the shock
Factor right and everybody else is like
I think the number one issue we have is
the economy I think the number one issue
we have is health care I think when Ken
and they go wrong with it this guy's
coming with a shock Factor saying nope
here's the number one issue you're
acting like he didn't talk about the
economy but those are not as number one
though those are not as number one I
think the Assumption was that Donald
Trump as a businessman knows more about
the economy than other people and he
does I didn't say he doesn't yeah my
point is take you've got to assume that
he was inflected in part because of his
attitude about the economy and he's
something that people thought he was
gonna look here's another thing about
Donald Trump I've never seen before
and my argument is he's a unique specie
that's what I'm saying uh I was with him
in Cleveland in 2016. we campaigned
together at black church
and I got to speak to him about 15
minutes privately
and I said to him there's one thing you
should apologize for
he said I know what you're going to say
what I say about uh uh John McCain I
said I couldn't care less I said you
said that George W bush led us into the
Iraq War
I said I know that you argue that you
didn't support the war fair enough but
nobody lied I've talked to to uh kind of
Lisa Rice I've talked to Colin Powell
they said the intel was wrong nobody
lied
I said the British were shooting at the
at the uh the the uh the Iraqis were
shooting at the British and American
Plains patrolling the Southern and
no-fly zones uh Sodom Hussein was
stealing from the oil for food program
we know he had chemical weapons because
he used them on the on the curse he used
them on the on the Persians
um he tried to assassinate uh President
George Herbert Walker Bush there were
lots of reasons by in the in the
resolution that was signed by the the
Senate and the in the house on why we
went to war nobody lied and I said
that's what Ted Kennedy's been saying
week after week after week we were told
lie after life like I said you were
giving the left
talking point to the media it's not
right anyone like this
however he never said it again
and see Donald Trump's way of
apologizing is to never say the same
wrong anything twice my point is he got
away with it he got away with Access
Hollywood
who else do you know that could survive
scandals like that nobody
so I'm just saying I've never seen
anything like it so when you're going we
need this we need this you're trying to
reverse engineer Donald Trump it's
Donald Trump I got a technical question
for you okay almost everybody that runs
for office has uh oh and you know I'm
hoping maybe you have a different
Insight than we do because we're not in
the world you're on you've been in it
for a while
everybody that runs or becomes president
there's stories about women that come
out you've had that Trump's had it you
know Reagan said it how come there's no
stories of Kennedy can I finish my point
Tom like seriously you got everybody
he's the famous guy doing that is that
two volts yeah okay so once again I'll
start from the beginning before Tom kind
of have to jump in so why is it that
every candidate that's what we're gonna
do about the time is the Wikipedia we
call him ugly he's not done yet he has
to do three more details until I ask my
question can I just do it Tom okay why
is it that every man that's run for
office or become a president has said
women from the past that's come up
you've had it uh Trump's had I think one
only from the past obviously I'm very
sarcastic you got 12. you got you got
we've got Clinton Biden Bush you got how
come there's no woman from Obama's past
Richard Nixon how come there's no one
from Obama Richard Nixon's past either
well back in the days there was no
social media so I'm going more like 50.
right so why why is it why it 40 years
why is it that Obama there's no woman
from his past are you think he just
didn't have game where you think like
you know because he's really good at
Secrets he's a good looking guy he has a
good shot left-handed yeah I've seen him
make the shot from the Pat from from the
side
is he dead devout of a Christian maybe
it's because his level of Devotion to
since we're talking about Obama let me
get this off my chest
my disappointment with Obama has nothing
to do with any of this obviously
um it's that he ran as the guy that
people thought was a guy who was in
Boston in 2004.
I was in the arena when he gave the
introduction speech to uh John Kerry
there's no blue America there's no
reason phenomenal speech phenomenal yeah
there's no black Americans nobody yeah
um I turned to my producer and I said
you know all they said was a bunch of
platitudes but he said him well
this guy's gonna run for president
someday so Obama decides to run before
he even knew where the bathroom was
and he's at a black church
and he's talking about how much racism
he thinks isn't there is in America and
this is really important he said
the Moses generation referring to the
generation of Martin Luther King has
gotten us quote 90 of the way there
close
he said My Generation he referred to his
generation as the Joshua generation has
to get us an additional 10 and I thought
that was reasonable because there was a
fox opinion poll 2002.
eight percent of Americans think that's
a possibility that Elvis is still alive
so you have to write off around 10 of
the American people so what he was
really saying in my opinion is we've
gotten to the point now where MLK's
dream of people
evaluating you based on content of
character within your own skin pretty
much been realized yeah he uh was on 60
Minutes when he was running
he hadn't yet caught up with Hillary but
he was coming otherwise they wouldn't
put him on there and Steve Croft the
correspondent said Senator if you don't
win will it be because of racism
and I'm at home and I said let's see how
he answered this question let's see if
he gives a Victor cred answer along the
lines of what Al Sharpton would say or
Jesse Jackson would say both of whom ran
for president and claim they didn't get
there because of racism
and Obama said no if I don't win it will
be because I've not articulated a vision
that's exactly what I said for him I
said I'm not going to vote for you yeah
tax spin regulate Obamacare but good for
you
he won with 53 of the vote he walked on
the Oval Office third week of January
2009 with 70 approval how then all of a
sudden people say you know I want my
taxes raised I I I want Obamacare no
they said at the very least he's going
to put a knife uh fork in the in the
notion that America remains systemically
racist
both blacks and whites thought race
relations would improve when he walked
in the Oval Office when he left both
blacks and whites thought it got worse
because for eight years he played race
card at the race card at the race card
from the Cambridge Police acted stupidly
to fight a son he looked like Trayvon to
embracing black lives matter to saying
that racism is in America's DNA to
having an AG Eric Holder who accused
people that wanted voter ID of engaging
in pernicious racism he he had Al
sharpened in the White House over 70
times he played the race card time and
time and time again that's not the
person that the American people thought
they hired and that's my problem with
him he's made things worse here's a guy
that had every Advantage best uh prep
school in the state of of Hawaii becomes
the president of Harvard Law review
Charmed existence and here he is playing
the race card that's not what the
American people thought they hired when
they when they voted for him in 2008 so
far basic question why so so let me
power power and vote he wants to get
black people angry because black people
will go in there like Lemmings and pull
that lever 90 95 of the democratic party
do you think because of social justice
and Equity whatever the hell that means
do you think his eye is it his ideas or
somebody that's put it in his ear
because of some stuff from the past
hurting his legacy do you think it's him
motivated for outside he wanted to get
reelected and he knew that if he it's
simple as that as simple as that
you think you think Democrats you think
Nancy Pelosi really believes America
systemically racist I mean do you think
James cliver really believes that you
think Obama really believes that BS he
knows it's not true but he also knows he
wants to win elections you don't win
elections by telling black people look
think about crime think about schools
think about jobs no you could win
election this guy over here is a racist
this guy over here uh wants to hold you
back this guy over here wants to oppress
you that's why we got this nonsense
about reparations by the way notice how
Obama hasn't said Jack about reparations
his whole career he opposed him where is
he oh he's been quiet say something he's
been very say something he doesn't want
to get canceled he knows he's going to
get canceled
and he wants to he wants to remain
relevant he hasn't said a damn thing
about this movement towards reparations
even though he's opposed to his whole
career uh and Larry I think where Pat
was going he's made things worse I I I I
agree I think I think playing the race
card the whole time to go in but anyway
what Pat I think was getting into was uh
about the whole the girl any no female
um Scandal or anything like that
recently I mean last podcast we talked
about a Tucker Tucker Carlson no I know
I know where you were going with that
yes and there here's my question not go
go there no no no no no no here's my
question Hilary why Tucker Carlson
probably I mean one of the highest
streaming looked at eyeballs right in
the in the history of Twitter X whatever
you want to call it why out of all
people at this specific time would you
bring up a man who has been on on camera
multiple times for 25 years stating
passing lie detector tests you know
signing affidavits I don't care about
his past this is what I did with Obama
why what do you think the motive is to
come up I mean the guy's not getting
money the guy doesn't look well at all
what's the motive behind going on on a
platform like that and what's the motive
behind Tucker interviewing him or the
guy going on the planet
what's Tucker's motivation I think he
thinks this news
really I think he thinks it's a story
that the media I think his angle is the
media were aware of this or could have
been aware of this should have been
aware of this but they wanted to protect
Barack Obama and they circled the wagons
around him the way they did around
Jeremiah Wright remember when Jeremiah
Wright came out yeah uh all of a sudden
uh
uh the media is not talking about this
until the video came out with him saying
uh KKK United States then they had to
talk about it I'll just ask you
directions so I think I think that's
what Tucker is saying that this was a a
bombshell story he probably would not
have been elected uh if this had been
covered by the media uh and uh and it's
an example of how bias the media are I
think that's what he said I'll just ask
you directly these guys both kind of you
know don't don't say these guys no no
don't do that don't do that you ask the
question do you want to say these guys
yeah I'm saying you guys ask the
question do I care whether Obama might
be gay do you think Obama's gay that's I
have no idea don't care yeah what I care
about what I said earlier that he ran
promising to be a racial uniter and
divided us and played the race car time
and time again racism is in America's
DNA are you effing kidding me the first
time Gallup asked white people if they
vote for a black president was it was in
the 50s and only around 30 said yes now
only about four percent said they
wouldn't vote for a black person so how
does how does DNA uh uh change like that
that's what I'm angry about him for this
he was a fraud he was a fraud on on
racial conciliation a huge fraud on that
the rest of the stuff the tax suspended
regulating I knew that but you don't
walk into the Oval Office of 70 approval
rating who are you talking about right
now you're talking about Obama about
Obama he's a fraud but Larry as much as
you're saying you don't care
there's a huge percentage of the
Republican base that actually believes
this and actually believes that Michelle
Obama isn't actually a man they call her
Big Mike so I know that this is not your
thing I I don't know anybody calls you
that stop Larry
before I came to Value timing four years
ago I never even heard that Michelle
Obama was a man I didn't think that
Obama was gay but I've heard this
multiple times hundreds of times you
must have heard this and what do you say
to that what do you say to the
Republican base would think that
Michelle Obama is a freaking man and
Obama's gay if the Republican base
thought that Michelle Obama was every
bit as as graceful as attractive as
Jacqueline Kennedy they still wouldn't
have voted for him because of his policy
so it doesn't matter
it's it's inconsequently I don't know
Larry I think you're skirting this one I
know I'm not
well well but because some people are
saying this like I've and Pat kind of
brought it up but I've been hearing this
too Larry that the reason Tucker brought
this up and had this guy speak is
because and how many times have we heard
it Pat from how many people that knew
something's out newsom's saying he's not
gonna run yeah the Kamala thing is a
possibility but that Michelle Obama is
going to come in and say Hey listen we I
need to save this everybody's all messed
up nobody's really running Joe Biden's
dying in front of him so you think
Tucker's motivation is to is to make
sure that Michelle Obama doesn't become
president they're saying I I didn't say
what I'm saying is people have been
saying online that this is one of those
okay if she does uh announce that she's
running they're going to have to address
this fact because nobody I've never seen
anybody ask Obama on camera okay hey
just really quick are you gay have you
ever done any gay homosexual activities
never once and they've been silent since
the day that this came out Larry
Sinclair Michelle Obama took a flight to
Spain and hung out with with friends and
Brock didn't go with her just say
Hillary Clinton was accused by Juanita
Broderick
of having that team around of
threatening her yep when after uh
Juanita Broderick said she'd been raped
by Bill Clinton yes
I've not heard anybody ask Hillary
whether that's true or false yep people
think that Hillary Clinton has committed
murder multiple times
my point is there are a lot of no-fly
zones uh the media has uh when it comes
to protecting people on the left and
this is not uncommon
um I couldn't care less whether Obama is
gay I couldn't care less whether or not
Michelle is is Big Mike
um I I think Obamacare Obamacare is an
Abomination uh I think what he did on
race relations set this country back uh
that's what I care about yeah you're a
policy guy but that's the exact TR if I
asked Trump that he'd be like yeah he's
probably gay yeah Michelle's probably a
man and that's why he gets eyeballs
I don't think Trump would say that
even conceded that Obama was born here
after spending money to to investigate
he started the whole birther class
no he did not start that he'll restart
at that 2008. oh that's correct Bingo he
promoted the hell out of it game change
she started it uh Cindy Cindy Blumenthal
was her top aide he goes to the
McClatchy newspapers and says Obama is
not from here he was born in Africa uh
and a guy named James Asher you can look
it up uh took the uh advice seriously
put somebody on it and they track it
down they found nothing nothing to it
with Hillary Clinton campaign they
started and everybody assumes Trump
started it but he did not Hillary did it
yeah but nobody knows that meaning like
I actually I think you're probably right
now they do millions of people now do
that's true but everyone I've done a
service of nothing if you did a poll
right now who started the birther claims
I would say 90 of people would say so
many things about Donald Trump are just
not true for example in November 2016 I
think it was around November before the
election anyway Bloomberg poll the
number one reason that likely voters
gave for not liking Donald Trump is that
they felt he had
demeaned a disabled reporter mocked a
disabled reporter he did not
we're talking about a guy named Serge
kovalevski wrote for one of the big
newspapers and Donald Trump publicly
said that people cheered the fall of the
Twin Towers
and nobody could find a story and then
he found a story and uh they went up to
search kovalevski wrote the story and
said did you see this he goes well you
know I sorted it well I wasn't sure
there was that many and so Donald Trump
mocked him in a town hall
uh he wasn't mocking his disability and
by the way the guy doesn't go like this
which is what Donald Trump did the guy
has an atrophied arm but he doesn't go
like this and uh Donald Trump did not
mock him but that's what people believe
uh there's a website called Catholic for
Trump
where Donald Trump has used his gesture
to mock himself to mock a naval body the
general it's what Donald Trump does
because he's the stand-up comic it's not
true just it's not true that Donald
Trump said there were good Nazis and bad
Nazis on both sides regarding
Charlottesville Charlottesville even
Jake Tapper two years later said you
know look went back looked at it he
wasn't saying that he was saying they're
good people and bad people on both sides
of the debate on whether or not there
should be a Confederate monument in in
the Public Square
but that's what a lot of people feel
well so so and the other big thing that
people think about Donald Trump is that
he was was leading an Insurrection on
January 6th when as you pointed out
how what what what part of I want you to
peacefully and patriotically make your
voices heard don't you understand so
many of the things that people hate
Donald Trump's guts for are simply flat
out false including that he started the
birthing movement he did not well this
goes to the bigger question about the
media I actually agree with can you
actually verify the Hillary Clinton uh
birther versus Trump because there's a
lot of people that believe
this video of of uh morning Scarborough
Morning Joe show where a guy named John
Holloman co-authored the book called
game changes on yeah John heilman can
you find that and uh Harold Ford is on
the panel and somebody mentions that
Hillary started well I didn't know that
I didn't know that and Joe Scarborough
turns to John Hyman said well John you
wrote the book Game Change what's the
truth he said I'm confirming the the uh
the notion that with Hillary Clinton has
started it John Highland said that well
it's only 10 years to find that clip if
you could Rob if you can somehow
uh yeah yeah that's it Joe right there
Joe Obama Muslim talk started with
Hillary 2015. right there
and then this talks about the birther as
well with Hillary can we play this well
the whole birthday thing is Obama's from
Africa
can you can you get audio or no Rob I
mean God you see that interview yeah I
mean the clintons questions
that was stunning it was stunning she is
asked on Face the Nation about uh who
with the state she said the state
department authorized it no there was
Dickerson didn't follow up with a
question who with the state department
that's just the campaign did not allow
that because that this interview was set
up so that certain questions on policy
were required for a certain amount of
time so then they could go into emails
for a certain amount of time and then
they would fast forward a little bit to
see if this is the one Rob just kind of
fast Texas
it started this started with Hillary
Clinton and it was about 20 seconds
right there that's good for spreading
the rumors okay go back 10 more seconds
this was the one yeah right let's say
one other thing too here we go it was
rich this weekend I guess we have to get
our digs in on Hillary Clinton here
because because I I thought we were
going to get through a segment without
talking about her but but for Hillary
Clinton to come out
and criticize anybody for spreading the
rumors about Barack Obama
when it all started on 60 Minutes when
it all started with her and her camera
she's a pro passing things around in the
Democratic primary rich now listen he
says he is the Republicans are wrong for
doing what they're doing it started this
started with Hillary Clinton and it was
scary
but Mika you can't tell me to stop when
you are when the two of you are making
comments if you have a if there's a
basis an actual evidentiary basis for
what you're saying
they're the ones that spread it in 2008
the spread what in 2008 Barack Obama may
not be uh Barack Obama may not be a
Christian we should ask Kyle in this
question
I don't I don't recall that but if
you're telling me that was the case I I
just don't recall John I was the case
[Laughter]
a week earlier she went on Andrew
Mitchell and it was all emails all the
time for the first 20 minutes of that
interview that's so she has that yeah so
you were right yeah of course
but more importantly a guy named James
Asher a-s-h-e-r who work for McClatchy
hold that up said that Sydney Blumenthal
approached him and said Obama is not
from here uh and he tracked it down and
found nothing to wow
got it and Cindy Blumenthal was so is
Hillary's hatchet man you know what's
interesting about that is that was in
what year Rob 15. that was 2015. this
was the year I literally used to watch
Morning Joe and Joe Scarborough Amiga
Brzezinski John heilman and everyone
that's on there literally every morning
for two straight years okay
and this was when Joe Scarborough was
actually a friend of Donald Trump so was
making presents kid they were he was at
their wedding Joe Scarborough used to be
a republican correct yeah and used to
demean Al sharp and sign a resolution
introduce a resolution calling Al
Sharpton race hustling uh demagogue
right and now they kiss each other's
butts well he's on his show yeah but
this is my point the Reverend yeah thank
you this is my point in in a in a few
short years from 2016 to the Trump
election so basically we are today the
media has completely gone to different
South Greece right agree completely gone
to different sides so here's my question
the media has already done this if
there's one thing I've learned since
Trump has been elected office that the
Deep state is real absolutely and they
do not want Donald Trump to be president
they didn't want him in 2016. they
didn't want him in 2020 they did
everything in their in their power to
get him out of office right and they're
going to do everything in their power to
do it again in 2024. so if he is elected
which is 50 50 at this point they're
going to do everything in their power to
belittle his candidacy or his presidency
he's a racist is why person
Russia this that the other they're going
to play clips of January 6th it's just
gonna happen over and over and over
again how does someone like Trump combat
the media big Tech Hollywood how does he
even go against that at this point the
good news is I said I was a cautious
pessimistic but the good news is
Donald Trump Republicans now have almost
half the Hispanic vote
Donald Trump got elected with eight
percent of the black vote in 2016. when
he ran in 2020 he got 12 that's a 50
increase he got 20 of the black male
vote
people are waking up
they're saying the nonsense and they're
seeing their pocketbook they go to the
gas station they go to the store they're
paying a lot more for the same stuff uh
and you can call Donald Trump all sorts
of names if you want all I know is I'm
paying a lot more for gas I'm paying a
lot more for chicken for bacon for milk
for for egg for cheese than I did before
yeah but that's Grassroots how do you
handle the top okay there's bottom up
and then top down so the top down the
media Hollywood big Tech everything even
the clearly the Deep State how does he
combat that because the the fear is it's
just going to be this antagonistic with
vindictive relationships the trust in
the media has never been lower and
that's because Donald Trump is
popularized the expression fake news uh
and disinformation uh you you combat it
by telling the truth and by standing
your ground which is why people love
Donald Trump so much he's a fighter so
it sounds like even though you're
running for president he has your vote
if he becomes a nominee
I I would rather be the nominee and I'll
ask him to be my running mate by the way
by the way you're running even though we
just verified by democrats that the
birther was started by Hillary can you
shake can you show the poll how it's
doing Rob I'm just curious to know
because
some people want to believe this they
have to believe it of course because
they can't admit that they're wrong
handle the truth from the movie you
can't handle the truth okay go to the
poll if you can Rob just to tell us if
you can show us how the poll is doing
percentage-wise even Hillary once
attacked Donald Trump for starting the
racist rumor that Donald zoom in a
little bit so we can see it zoom in a
little bit 24 still believe it's Trump
25 even though you just showed like you
just showed like eight minutes ago
before that that's our poll right that's
our report 76 believe yeah for sure but
think about 25 what she's trying to say
is he imagine a poll of people that are
not watching the show can you can you
find a poll of people asking who started
the birth thing there's a regular poll I
assure you the majority of Americans
especially Democrats believe that Donald
Trump started it and while he's looking
for that later I think something that
you said that there's no question Donald
Trump promoted it of course but starting
it he did not start it well sometimes
they say you don't want it to be first
you need to be secular so like look at
Myspace defunct look at Facebook their
trillion dollar company Trump was second
he he was the man by the way you have to
give Hillary credit because she's the
first one that said it's a you know the
election was a fraud first one that said
birther first one yeah
email like she's a vegetables
and says you better keep your mouth shut
or else or else nothing and Larry how is
she so untouchable can you explain that
to me like I don't get well well she did
lose the election against Donald Trump
in 2016 because her uh unfavorable
ratings were as high if not higher than
Donald Trump so kind of offset each
other wow but but I'm saying how how is
she is she that embedded with the FBI
and the doj and the did she can do she
can literally kill someone and get away
with it literally allegedly allegedly
literally well I'm not going to concede
about that part but uh yeah of course I
mean the the DNC wasn't was uh was in
fixed for her Donna Brazil won gave her
campaign questions remember I mean
debate questions to make sure she was
going to win the uh win the nomination
uh look there's a conspiracy of Interest
with the media Democratic Party big Tech
Hollywood Academia and we're against and
there and they're United against
Republicans they believe Republicans are
bad people or evil people only care
about the rich uh that if you are
pro-life you're anti-female uh if you
want strong borders you're you're a
racist that's how they feel and that's
what we're up against Larry last
question because I know we got to wrap
up your friend your good buddy your
Compadre Charlemagne the God you were
just you we mentioned them a little bit
earlier yes uh you were on his show The
Breakfast Club massive audience you know
massive black audience
um breaking news I just found out you're
black that's crazy I just found that out
yeah that's just what amazing respect
but you were on about two weeks ago and
he did a reaction video and he uh so
politely called you the Donkey of the
Day and he went Ham on you brother so
you know he's got a huge voice in the
black community obviously what do you
say to him what do you say to the black
community that they think you're the
donkey when you're just like look
personal power personal self-improvement
account ability well he called me the
Donkey of the Day as I recall because I
didn't make the debate stage and I
complained about it and I I was on his
show saying that there's no systemic
racism uh in America and here Larry is
complaining about the systemic way he
did not make the debate stage yeah
that's what he said make to me that made
no sense and frankly I believe he called
me the doc the other day because if you
look at the comments and I have a friend
who read every single one of them and
these are his people 85 of them thought
he got his butt kicked yep yeah so would
you go back again oh absolutely in fact
okay I I'm tentatively scheduled to go
back how do you win over not only
Charlemagne but the people who think
like Charlemagne because there's
millions of them tell the truth
yeah tell the truth but you know this
I've been doing this for 40 years what
you guys are doing been for 40 years and
I've noticed something when somebody
calls up and I always took pride in
taking people who disagree with me no
one in the middle of a conversation is
going to go you know what you're right
yeah yeah I I I've been in I've had any
Epiphany it's the person who's driving
who's listening that I'm talking to
and so I I know that Charlemagne the
guy's not gonna go you know Larry I
never thought about this and you're
right there's no systemic racism I need
to rethink my assumptions he's not gonna
do that but his listeners will and if
you look look at the comments many of
them have not saying they suddenly
become card carrying um Trump supporting
Republicans but they're beginning to
rethink their assumptions they know
fatherlessness is a big bigger problem
than systemic racism they see the
schools they see the crime
well I can't give you one quick one
quick story go for it when I was in high
school there was a guy named Gilbert and
he was a iffy kind of student he wasn't
a bad student but he wasn't somebody
that was academically oriented as I was
I told you my my dad used to have a cafe
and I like didn't like working for him
so when my dad and I stopped talking to
each other 15 years old I decided to get
me a job in the Summer with the with the
county L.A County you got to go downtown
and take this big test it must have been
three or four hundred people this is in
the in the late 60s most of the people
there were white
and one of the guys taking the test was
this guy named Gilbert from my high
school and I saw him and um
it was a three-hour exam uh math uh
reading comprehension stuff like that
and then you had to go out in the hall
and then they grade the paper you come
back in so I see Gilbert he goes hey
Larry what's up I said what's going on
Gilbert he said watch out they're gonna
get us
who's going to get us he said the white
people are creating these exams yeah
I said they're going to get us he said
watch them flunk us so we go back in
about 300 people as I said they call out
your uh name if you are to remain
meaning you pass a test
and then it would give you a bunch of
options for jobs and if you didn't get
your name called you had to leave so I'm
sitting there calling off the names of
course my name was called
as were the names of a number of black
people
and then you hear a screeching of chairs
into people who weren't called get up to
leave so Gilbert walks right by me and
he says as he sees me sitting there
obviously my name was one of those who
was called who was named
he said what did I tell you
how can somebody make an argument that
white people are going to flunk black
people I'm black I'm sitting there I'm
not flunked and he walks by me and he
says what did I tell you
this is the mentality this is a sick
this is an illness and a lot of black
people have that we have to raise our
game I remember the Dream Team and the
Olympics
because we began losing matches we can't
stand college kids anymore and expect
them to win 92. so the Dream came
crushes everybody
well now we still sin the best we don't
crush people anymore
it's competitive now because the rest of
the world raised their game they didn't
lower the hoop they didn't widen the
hoop they raised we need to raise our
game as black people if you look at a
graph of how much homework a black kid
does every night versus the white kid
versus Asian kid it's like this
if you don't put in the time
you're not going to get the results we
have to stop bitching and moaning and
whining about systemic racism and raise
our effing game that's what I'm all
about Larry Elder that is Larry by the
what's the website to go to for your
campaign is there website larryelder.com
can we put that link below please and my
book is as goes California my mission to
rescue the Golden State and save the
nation as you can see my goal is Tom are
modest we we got all of that below Larry
once again thank you for coming out gang
we got another podcast I believe this
Thursday yes Candace Owens will be
Candice Owens will be here this Thursday
looking forward to that way can I one
more yeah shut up I've got I've got a
coaching tree
uh Stephen Miller one of Donald Trump's
top aides I first had him on my radio
show when he was 14 years old he was a
student at Santa Monica High and I
thought he was brilliant and over the
years I had him on the show
69 times reason I know the numbers
because he counted them it's a weird
number but yeah uh yeah Candace Owens
refers to me as her Mentor she wrote the
forward to my book escorts California I
wrote the foreign
the guy that's the editor-in-chief of
Breitbart News his name is Alex Marlow I
gave him his first job in conservative
radio Michelle Malkin first time she's
ever on radio or TV she was on my radio
program
Ben Shapiro has publicly credited me
with getting him into the into this
business in this field Andrew Breitbart
as publicly credited me was inspiring
him to get into this field uh there's a
there's a syndicated uh cartoonist named
Branco Antonio Branco
I liked his work I went to my syndicator
I said this guy's brilliant he goes no
we don't like him he's brilliant we
don't like him so over the years I was
sending the best ones he now has a
syndicated deal with uh with the Creator
Syndicate so I'm very proud that I've
been able to influence a lot of these
young respect young young people yeah
respect and by the way and we can add
names that you forgot to bring up that's
many other names that I brought it up
Reuben a bunch of other people that we
came out to that as well right but it's
great thank you for your service thank
you for your voice you're doing a great
job it's very necessary please continue
thank you gang have a great one we'll do
it again on Thursday take care bye-bye
can you please